[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
testing
four feet four we'll go
four five three two eight can you guys
hear me
four five three two eight i'll be
checking the chat
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
second testing this this works right man
one two eight
six seven put that in the chat
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi this is lord sovereign from the iron
lord podcast
as you guys may recall a few months back
king david otw announced an amazing
giveaway for the xbox series x
well i'm proud to announce that the iron
lords podcast will once again be giving
away another console
at the end of this year and that console
will be a playstation
5. you heard correctly so
how do you get in on this amazing
giveaway let me explain
if you're already a member of the realm
you're good to go if you support us
either on patreon
or youtube you already have a ballot to
win this amazing console and if you
support us on both platforms
you have two ballots to win this amazing
console as you also have two ballots to
win
an xbox series x so if you're not a
member of the realm
what are you waiting for head on over to
patreon.com
go to the ironlord's podcast patreon
page become a member of the realm
to get your chance to win a playstation
5.
you can also join us on youtube iron
lord podcast
become a member of the realm and you
will also have
a ballot to win a playstation 5 console
and if you want to support us on both
platforms you'll have two
ballots for each system to win either a
playstation 5 console or of course as
king david said
and xbox series x this is an amazing
opportunity
that the iron lords podcasts are so
happy to bring to our community because
you guys give so much back to us
so again if you're not a member of the
realm yet what are you waiting for
go out join the realm on either patreon
or youtube and until next time i'll see
you at the round table
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there we go
[Music]
all right welcome to episode 179 of the
iron lords podcast
i am your host yet again
i'm not saying that in the stream
not at all sir what's obliged thank you
very
and it's much beautiful sunday here on
the lord's day
we have a lot of stuff to talk about
ladies and gentlemen and we have
the four horsemen of gaming in the
building all four horsemen today but
cuatro exactly so you know the ball
you should say it in spanish yo yo yo yo
break that down for dudes you should be
doing your
intros in spanish
let me say that let's take it all back
let's bring it over
to the hip-hop jump that's right
[Laughter]
[Applause]
get it no i listen i'm my hispanic it's
decent
it's not perfect i know some people are
gonna you know correct me
oh my god remember tomorrow first of all
let's go like we got gerald mack
welcome joe mac to the realm put them
crest in the chat ladies and gentlemen
thank you sir then we got smitty smith
off the back
with the five dollars we chat salute
good people and welcome back my warlock
brother lord
oh my god thank you brother
no doubt so let's get into these intros
with four horsemen of gaming
first up we have the young wolf of the
iop the difficult game conqueror
and the co-host of the iron lord podcast
lord addict what's going on brother
i'm tired let's go
no it's not the stress man i just didn't
have much sleep last night
i don't know no doubt no doubt so we
have returning to the realm today well
you know what let me go to king first we
have
the incredible hulk of the ilp the king
of statues
beloved lord king what's going on my
brother yo i'm fantastic yeah hold on a
second
turn the beat
[Music]
i'm excited that we said they already
they cast she-hulk for the
for the watch the disney plus series
yeah it's moving forward i just love
that they're touching on all these
characters that
not a chance in hell that we're going to
the movie for themselves and you know
what you know what i do love
i love that the fact that keanu reeves
has become
every hero inside the marvel universe
yeah
he's going to be the silver surfer no i
heard he's going to be moon knight
[Laughter]
what's up man what you been playing this
week i know there's something i know a
prediction you made earlier in the year
came
true sir shout out to my man dealer
gaming how you doing boy
i told you i will not buy that game
until it hit game pass you know what
phil
said give that man a lack
put that game inside game pass now
[Music]
october 1st is crazy
so tell me what did you think because i
know what i thought when i threw that
game on what did you think
yo is everything that everybody was
talking about
ain't it though i was like oh they
brought these dudes
oh my god yo and now i see the height
where people was talking about
yo if they could do a halo mixed with
doom collabo
that'd be crazy yo it definitely would
be crazy it definitely would
oh man ah that i'm just thinking about
the edtech
and the things that they can do yeah
yeah
yeah i mean it's it's gonna be so
interesting like the cross pollination
of all of these because you know it's
gonna happen at some point like at some
point something's gonna go down
some team you don't expect to take over
franchise is gonna do it maybe not even
just permanently but
side stories whatever we're gonna see a
lot of that stuff though yeah
it's just too much talent yeah it's so
much talent there's so much stories that
they can tell
um i'm really excited um because i
pre-installed
uh yes tactics um
and i'm really inside excited to to play
that on my series x
um and all the new information that i
was hearing about
uh how you're able to do certain things
with the series x like you before you
buy you can
install a game so i was like i'm i'm
excited about that but um my game pass
stuff this week
neon the best has captured my soul i'm
locked in
an eternal struggle with this game
and i almost got everything unlocked in
it i just i
really really love that game it's a
really great game okay
so it's been that in destiny and and
doom
okay without no doubt that we have
returning to the realm
well he was about he's been back he's
been back
but back on the east coast the boss lord
cognito what's going on brother
welcome morning morning gentlemen good
morning you guys say that with more
vibes
here you gotta you got us here
you
[Laughter]
[Music]
actually come back in the east coast you
know what it says and get back to the
east coast and all that stuff but first
of all the game stuff i just want to
thank
y'all my brothers you know what i'm
saying i know i've been going through it
mama cognito
has been going through it but uh she's
improving you know what i'm saying
we made a positive turn so shout out to
you guys you know what i'm saying for
sending me the encouragement
while i'm going through this difficult
time and then also shout out to
everybody in the room anybody who dm me
or
chatted me just to check on me see how i
was doing because it's been tough y'all
it's been tough but uh like i say turned
to corner
mama cognito is coming through you know
what i'm saying so still just going to
stand by for a couple of things that's
what i saw
is hosting yeah you know the attic's
been holding the dell for us but um yes
a little salute to that but as far as
that on
one thing i've been doing is just been a
lot of xcloud
a lot a lot i've been really getting a
chance to test it and uh especially when
mama cog is sleeping and resting i get a
chance to uh
pull that kishi we raise akishi out king
you know what i'm saying
and um and you're getting your um real
switch love on
like your phone is really switching from
a phone to a game device
it's been phenomenal what's up bro so
that means you've been frauding on hades
is that what you're trying to tell me
yes yes
yes that triple a uh outer worlds
experience
seems to trump everything else right now
let me ask you a question so did you
purchase that hades game
are you absolutely right i did i'm not
i'm not talking about that
i purchased it for the flight when i
flew back for most of them but
i played that and then shout out to hulk
i was playing a lot of two-point
hospital that game is hilarious i was
doing that
i don't want to kill them
yes yes okay particularly yeah but i was
doing the oh what you got like i said
i'm doing razer kishi i've been doing
other world shout out to um obsidian
apparel to gargon
dlc giant i'm rocking that man shout out
to the worst implemented dc
dlc in the history of games shout out to
microsoft oh
yeah having a great game and showing how
they can just tear
you up yeah you know what let me tell
you something microsoft this is what you
do
if you have a dlc that happens to be
triggered while you're playing the game
what you do is when you purchase that
dlc let it be a different save spot
right that remembers your
progress in the game that i don't have
to have 40 different saves at places
that i don't care about
that i didn't know the dlc was going to
be about so then
why don't you have that so i can click
to that part of the game
where i was before that i didn't know
what was gonna happen that money that i
paid for
for a game yo i'm really so pissed off
that is the worst dlc
implementation ever and you know what
you did you made sure that i'm not
buying another dlc
for that damn game what's the issue he
got knocked out he got locked
out where his save progresses the dlc
so apparently the dlc occurs not at the
end game per se right
so once you finish the actual original
game
if you get past a certain point you're
locked out of the dlc
i i'm right before the last mission so
and if you purchased i would agree with
that no i i played the dlc oh so you
know my stupid ass
right i'm sorry my i'm really upset
sorry am i bad
my stupid behind i i got to the end
i ended i loved the game right so i got
to the end of the game right before you
about to do whatever you about to do
and i'm like a couple of click steps
away because i say right inside the room
after i did what i did
and then the game goes into his little
thing and then you answer their
questions and then it gives you
an outcome right and then i'm thinking
that it's going to be a game plus mode
right after
with all the stuff that i got right and
i can go back to these worlds
and just frolic around op as i
am that doesn't happen
[Laughter]
start over and let it go do it again
from scratch which are nothing but
that's why you need to have multiple
saves right
no but you know what no no that's that's
you shouldn't no
you that's just a poor implementation of
a dlc
and and you listen if sony did it i
would i would have cursed him
but i didn't have that issue like i
think if you wasn't at the end
i know i beat the game what you mean it
wasn't that way he said
you know there's
but you had multiple saves that you knew
where you were in the game
i had one save i only played that game
one time so how the hell did you get to
the
okay now we're not gonna do this no i
i'm just
i'm ken time time time no no no no no no
no no i paid money
i want to know how he did this we'll
talk about that after the podcast
it was a good it was a good dlc too i
beat it last night actually i was in the
party
for the love of god for the love of god
how the hell did you get off the
platform because i went back to the
beginning to where my [ __ ] was
and i tried to get out again for me all
it was was
in the ship yeah you just got a package
you get up you get a ups package like
and then you open up the package and
then
and then someone attacks you well i'm
gonna tell my time okay
i know you wasn't at the end of the game
i'm talking you just got it
so addict just save point when you came
back in the game you was at that
at the end i was at that well i just do
manual saves i don't do auto saves
okay i do manual saves as well sir i'm
just
i'm just clarifying because i will
really be playing this game today
all right so i made it all the way back
to the ship and i tried to leave and
they said i'm
locked here i can't oh you must have all
you manuals
i always man you say before the last
mission you're on the last mission
that's what it is
all right yeah what you need to do is is
load up an auto save or something
or i think if you beat i try to beat the
game again and it might put you right
before you did the last mission i can't
remember
[Laughter]
talking about it anyway
oh no we don't judge this out yet thanks
everybody for the love and all stuff and
uh yeah we've been doing a lot of this
cloud really playing that in the wild
really loving it it's really cool and um
yeah that's been
pretty much it man so we're gonna get
into i know we got a lot yeah yeah i
mean no doubt real quick before i get
into what i did yeah whatever but uh
listen man like when i heard that that
lady cog was not doing well like my
heart was
it was in my hands man because we said
it here a million times like
we're not here if if not for her like
really like she facilitated all of our
foolishness when we were young
um and i was thinking to myself like you
know love
loving the door my mother but there's no
not a chance in hell she was letting us
be in my house
every weekend for years on end of my
house
you know and it had the whole block and
the credit literally the whole block
and she and facilitating that kept us
from
doing other things that we need to be
doing so
man i i'm just so happy she's doing
better like that's what i'm doing about
that yeah
patience and the love of a buddhist monk
yes she does
i told her i said king i said i said
they said they love
everybody sent love you know what i'm
saying they know how much you know she
amazes me so it was really
really cool man definitely dope and uh
what we got saw we got any uh
no we gotta do hold on a second so real
quick what i did i've been
a little time i had to play any sort of
games week it was i told you i hate this
is that crack
hayden oh it's just consumed
20 minutes a day that i can play so
that's what i'm playing um so yeah let's
get first of all let's get these super
chats because we are yes please yeah we
got a lot
you guys uh you guys don't don't don't
let don't let up
so let's go real quick so we got cinder
vendetta with the 10
super chat unfortunately the ps5
hands-on demo didn't show much at all
at least we got a look at the console
and the loading speeds looked fast
but disappointed with the lack of ps5
info so
far yeah yeah
and i know you say that but yes yeah
then we have j.w as a shill with the
five dollars
king is it true that the almighty
spider-man modern rolex
paired with the god level ssd produces a
1440p
60 frames per second experience no 4k at
60
is this a ps4 pro plus oh wow
i told you before they just catching up
to that xbox one x
mm-hmm wow wow
and we got there we got j-mo money with
the two dollars super chat ps4 and ps5
saves are
like cogs beard imaginary
[Laughter]
two dollars we chat saba here
auditioning for telemundo and facts
everybody had to do that everybody had
to be a thing yo i i was kind of fired i
was
feeling that uh let me see there we have
smitty smith with the two dollar super
chat
keanu reeves gonna play lord sob next
week yeah
let's do it baby
then we have squirrely down with the two
dollar super chat king out here looking
like miss cleo
call me now then we got fixed with g
with the two dollars super chat
fam broke the rpg rule save often and
everywhere if i did
listen to me i i messed up i
i call for pins please
you can't be trusting those rpgs um and
we got michael
aka best sized finest with two dollars
we chat good morning lords hope all is
well
sir and we have our brother italian
clowns with the five dollars
android podcast anyone lend me a dollar
i need to buy game pass because ps now
is too expensive
and let's put them crushed in the chat
for the newest member of the realm
sparty on i like that party on welcome
to the realm
sir party on party arm all right so
here's a moment
so from sparty on then we have rmb3 with
the 5
super chat good sunday morning if i have
to buy ghost over again and start from
the beginning on ps5
i want jim ryan's name wbox podcast
sends their regards thank you that's
what's up thank you brother
what was the actual
[Music]
was there any truth to the boot up
sequences or the ssd size i tagged you
guys in and king
what did you think of that joker bust
um if you're talking about the infiniti
studio joker bus
i think infinity studios is if you went
to bus like that bruce lee bust that i
put up it's it's amazing
i feel like a pause should be here
because you
okay
[Laughter]
so some some dudes think about me some
weirdo
like cog um but a stack guys understand
that
means nothing from the waist down
everything
i'm back
no exactly like he leaves that to me now
he could just talk reckless right now i
love it
i could be y'all this is awesome
we have eaglespad76 with the 2 chat can
you use external hd on ps5
also transfers game i'm assuming you can
but again we don't know
we know what we can do in that on the
series x that's what something's here
um then we have smitty smith well you
gonna need
y'all ready for that microsoft buy of
tech land
so we caught up now no we caught up so
lord cog before we get into
our patreon and our youtube giveaways
we have a new scribe of the month sir oh
we jumping right into that
yeah i'll leave that to you because you
know more details about it
can can you hit my can you hit my music
ain't no music i just wanted to say that
hit the music
[Laughter]
remember that over there as you already
know launchinggaming.net man
wow what a month it has been absolutely
tremendous man in our our peak
viewership this month
i mean shout out to the entire team it
has been
what a journey for you know almost a
year old and to see this growth and see
this thing continue in a positive
direction
so um yeah masturbate to the entire team
soon to the editorial team
but as you know here on iop you know i
mean we we do this thing
we want to celebrate you know the great
scribes in the realm and
this month you know we have someone who
really went above and beyond
and he is in the chat right now muted
hopefully but uh
it is lord jean scheifmeier i hope i
pronounced your last name correct
salute you because like i said you had a
fantastic month you know
obviously it's been a pleasure working
with you you know since pax
you've come on to the team and you are
really you're really an anchor to the
team
and tremendous work the articles have
been amazing
he's a source of playstation news he's a
source of yakuza news
you're gonna say he's always on the
front line he's always on the floor so
lord jean our scribe
of the month congratulations brother
speech
you know uh i think it was like a year
ago now
i was getting ready to leave for a tokyo
game show or coming back in tokyo game
show and you guys have put a tweet out
we're looking for writers and i was like
you know fake until you make it here we
go
[Laughter]
and uh yeah it was a it's been pretty
cool it's been a lot of fun you know
uh spending my nights and weekends uh
just being able to talk about video
games and having a platform
to uh to talk about video games and and
meeting with publishers and developers
every day or
exchanging emails every day has just
been pretty crazy for the past year
awesome brother yeah two things that
stand out for me
uh during your tenure at launch of
gaming.net is one you were the first to
really get ahead of four guys before
everyone else you knew this thing was
going to be a hit so i thought that was
amazing right now you got an amazing
article right now off
what to do with that old console before
upgrading yesterday which is cool
and you're also my source for um i
believe that the editorial do every
month a circle
uh crossware for playstation right yeah
there's a monthly editorial on
uh the roundup for the playstation 5
news and just kind of
uh think think tank ideas of like what's
going on with them which is
not a lot right now and um yeah we
about november of last year we put
together an article for the most
anticipated games of 2020 and i had fall
guys on it and then we met with the team
in february
i'm playing the game and i'm at pax i'm
screaming at the director i'm like this
is going to be the biggest game on the
floor
dude brother make sure you get your
rewards as we discuss that
that's that all that stuff good stuff is
on the way you know
you know what i like most about gene i
love the fact his
uh utilization of the speed force um
when we was at pax and he was at the
whack party
oh yes the pictures of
our party and i swear i got one drink
and turned around and he was standing
right now
now salute you know another gmo is uh
we're with platinum games and uh
yeah i have to do
you know pandemic so somebody cough in a
room
so you got to see lord g face do the
face like
oh no
i know somebody you see
again these awesome memories and moments
you know when you're at
gaming conventions and things of that
nature so but again all jokes aside
salute the lord g man that's a hard
working dude
i'm looking forward to it again you're
you're an old-school gamer like like
most of us here except
you know what the the dreamcast
the dreamcast comparisons with tony hawk
i'm really looking forward to sit down
with that because that
again you don't see many people doing
things like that a lot of people just
don't have the hardware anymore to be
able to make those comparisons so
i'm excited to see that absolutely
absolutely what else we got self
all right so first off let's welcome to
the realm lord chetval
twisted cow yeah absolutely
in the chat thank you so much for the
support brother so speaking of support
this is the time of month when the iron
bank opens up its
coffers and gives back to the realm
once again thank you all for your
support both on patreon and on youtube
none of this happens without you guys
every single week every single month we
get new members in
it's it's it's baffling and amazing to
me so thank you so much so
this is our our little time of the month
when we get back a little bit so let's
start off with this 10
gift card giveaway and to those of you
who have yet contacted me with your
information
once again remember if you support us on
youtube
there really isn't a whole lot for me to
go on in terms of finding you so you're
if you're not in the chat if you're not
hearing when you actually win it is
difficult
for me to get to you um patreon is
different i have a whole bunch of your
information
and a lot of you also don't have twitter
accounts so again if
i can't reach you i can't get you your
stuff so please please please please
please
if you hear this and you know you want
in the past um just get get at me and i
will take care of you
um so first off yeah 10 gift card
giveaway
just get it let's get it and that
goes to
without no doubt congratulations sir you
know what to do
actually put your tell your telling your
twitter again for the youtube guys if
they ever you know find
that your ad yeah actually yeah exactly
you can reach me at lordsab iop
just hit me in the dm and you guys uh
just give me your information if i
happen not to have it
and i will get out your stuff to you as
quickly as possible when it comes to
these codes
it's instantaneous as soon as i get your
information and i know where to contact
you
you'll have that code in your dm so no
doubt um
so let's move on to this 20 gift card
the giveaway is roofing
roofing all right congratulations these
are two new names
again thank you for dropping off the bag
thanks for the uh rng rg this is rng
all right and let's get into this
teespring giveaway
yes let's get the drift from team we got
new stuff oh we got a whole bunch we got
a new stuff
you know we got a lot of new stuff here
check this store out yeah we're gonna
get a chance
you want to rep the lawyers during the
pandemic we got you got you bro we got
you
fire stuff all right so the winner of
the gift card the teespring giveaway is
jb golden oh jb
golden all right what's up what's up
maybe i'm doing the drum thing scares me
a little bit
[Laughter]
the first time in a while that we've
gotten basically three new names like
yeah
so that that just goes to show like i
said thank you guys because we're
getting
new supporters every single week it is
fantastic
keep spreading the word of the lords you
know that you know what to do
bringing people to the round table in
the realm that's what you do so again
thank you so much we really appreciate
it
like at the top of the show you saw my
uh my my little thing when i got a good
part when it came to when it came to the
playstation
you're gonna see uh king david's later
on um
guys you only have a few weeks left yeah
you only
have a few weeks left join the realm on
patreon join the realm on youtube
get your ballots in to win these
consoles yes i'm telling you right now
because
it's hard out there in the streets no
[Music]
all right so that is that the rigmarole
and everything is done we taking care of
business and the bills so let's jump
into this first topic of the week and as
i said before the main event is usually
the first event on the iron lords
podcast we're going to get right down to
it
um we are expecting hopefully
a guest
exactly so the first topic of the day is
the xbox series x is out in the wild
ladies and gentlemen
have it media has it people flossing on
twitter with it paul you know
everybody's
posting their pictures with it i saw
tony polanco up it
you know it's in my window holding it up
like
danny payne you're hanging out in an
alley somewhere with xbox music i don't
know what that's about but
everybody has this series x people are
talking about it um
so there's embargoes basically on a lot
of stuff but the first stuff that
everybody's
allowed to talk about is basically boot
up speed um
loading speeds um in terms of uh back
compact games
the speed at which these games are
running resolution stuff like that so
cog this is your topic actually
that's right i'm sorry this is your
topic go ahead and set it up
i want the host to set it up all right
so look man obviously
you know the xbox series x has been
going out to a lot of media influencers
and
you know people know so you know they've
got the chance to get the hands on it's
obviously there's an
nba or specific things that they can uh
talk about and speak of the devil
we have windows central oh
jess corden the filmic jazz corden
mr bone cream himself the creator of the
rant tomato tomatoes
best co-host what's going on sir how you
doing
hey there how are you guys doing not so
bad i haven't long woke up so i've got
my
cup of cup of tea and so i apologize if
i'm slightly slower than usual
she's going to be very slow but that's
all right just
blame addict for waking you that's all
yeah we appreciate you brother first of
all salute man they've been watching
following the site seeing what you guys
are doing
and um loving the coverage well you know
first of all i love what you do with
xbox two and ran that's number one you
guys are amazing
and number two is uh number three for
jokes uh i love that you taking loads of
game without that writer salute
i just say that different jokes
but anyway all jokes aside no seriously
man i know you're one of the first um
guys that actually have you know a
series x in hand
you put it through the paces don't want
to get you in trouble because i know you
got things you can't talk about but
just so far your experience how has it
been with the xbox series x
yeah so like there are things i can't
talk about yet because we are running on
a basically an insider ring
for a press um we've got like access to
a specific pool of games i guess games
that um games that have dynamic
resolution and dynamic frame rates
that benefit the most from the xbox
series x uh x
the xbox series x like um like for
example
monster on tarzan unlocked frame rate
which means it gets to about 35
frames per second on the xbox one x but
on the xbox series x it goes all the way
up to 60 because
dynamic unlocked frame rate whereas
other games are
hard locked to 30 frames per second not
necessarily going to see
as much benefit so i think that's pr
partially why they've locked press out
of the full library
um but uh you know it is what it is and
uh as as as you might have seen tom were
on tweeting they
unlocked a further 200 games for press
to to play around with
um yesterday um just to cut you just so
it's more than 500 uh
games that it was wrong i saw your tweet
what are we up to now um i don't know
off the top of my head it's somewhat
like
700 now 800 or something like that
but the pla the plan is and this is what
xbox pr says the plan is
they're linked to one of the blog posts
where jason ronald said the plan is on
launch day to have the full library
there
so i saw some like you know uh fud being
spread around that the press the
the press pool is the full library back
and pack games that's not the case
the full library is planned to be there
on launch day and
at the speed of which they're unlocking
the games i'd expect that to be the case
but um yeah i can't talk about the
operating system but you might have seen
it from some of the videos
like the the sexy animated background
for example uh
i don't know if you saw that uh that is
currently live uh i suppose
there's no reason i can't talk about
that considering they've put a video out
about it
um but that is currently live on the
xbox dashboard uh
it looks really stunning in person so um
that's nice and uh you know i think
they've got
more surprises planned for those sort of
animated style backgrounds
um down the line but you know
the things i can talk about primarily
the industrial design and the hardware
it is a stunning piece of kit it's not
as big as you think
like with this whole comparison video
and i was like
man was the playstation 2 really that
big you know like
it's playstation 2 is actually slightly
taller than the xbox series x which is
like
or slightly shorter i can't remember
which one it was but it's comparable in
height which
i was i couldn't remember the xps2 being
that big
and then and then like you compare it to
loads of other things and
uh it's really not as big as you think
um
i just sort of slide it nicely into
myself like
vertical vertically i know people who've
got like a more compact self might
struggle to fit in but
i think it really is designed to be set
vertically because the heat
comes out of the top pretty pretty
hardcore you know
the console itself is cool like but
the microsoft's done a good job of
making sure all the heat is not in the
system it's
coming out of the system so you're gonna
want you're gonna want that top vent
you know with a lot of space to get rid
of the heat right otherwise that heat's
going to be going in your console and
that's not what you want
speaking of heat that seemed to be
another little yeah
noise yeah i would ask you those two
questions silent
it's just damn silent like it's it's
switched on right now
um i could probably get my microphone
close enough to it
so you can listen to it but honestly
it's it's just completely silent
um but we haven't really had any game
that really pushes it yet
obviously no game with ray tracing right
um available yeah
uh some of the games that would make my
xbox one x noisy like well
frankly monster yeah is a pretty
not the most optimized game i've ever
played um
but you know it's you know runs
perfectly well and
completely silent on series x um you
know
you don't even get that mechanical hard
drive clicking noise when it's read
writing data
because it's you know ssd completely
silent
um so that's that's awesome too
um so like that nvme
difference you're noticing right off the
bat as far as the the loading times and
as far as um
like i said games with unlocked frame
rates so i noticed you me i know you
played a lot of monster hunter
like how significant is that difference
you know
playing it for on the xbox one x and
then now on the series x
i think like monsanto has been the game
that for me
is shows the biggest difference across
the board
not only does it benefit from quick
resume the most because
like in destiny for example if you're
logged out if you
if you're idle in destiny that kick you
off the server
but in in monstante if you're idle you
just sort of you go into offline mode
so you can just leave your character
like quick resume ready at the mission
table at all times
so no matter how many games you've
booted up since then you can just
instantly jump back into monster hunter
at the mission table ready to go ready
to reconnect
no loading screen no menus no like login
no
no character selection you just ready to
go straight away
so over time that's like going to save
you a lot of time
beyond that yeah it's sort of like um
it's the uh it's the loading speeds a
man
because like monsanto has like it's an
area based game
so like you load into like a forest area
to fight certain monster or
an ice area to fight another monster or
whatever those a lot of times are pretty
hefty
and i haven't measured them like
empirically because i felt like i
got my xbox one at least yeah at least a
minute now it's like
if i just it's just basically instant
like
back in the day i say back in the day
last week
uh when i was playing xbox one x it's
like you could
you could like you had time to like fire
up twitter and start sending tweets and
stuff like that during the loading
screens
now it's just instant you know like
literally talking about five seconds
eight seconds to load up
load up some of the more intensive areas
in the game uh
destiny takes about 10 seconds to load
up one of the areas as well
oh no yes yes that's great that's great
news we like to hear that i'm so
i'm so done with this pc stuff people
understand
i swear destiny feels bottlenecked by
the animation i'm sure destiny could
load up even faster if it wasn't for
like the slow
spaceship animation animations yeah yeah
yeah and and then
what's it made not to cut you just one
two things one what's amazing is a lot
of these
everything you're talking about these
game this is just the brute force of the
series x so we're not even talking about
from an optimization
standpoint or a patch standpoint then
two things two shout outs actually i
want to shout out back off he's in the
chat aka giuseppe
from splash damage he wanted to shout
you out he said i just connected with
his naked friend jessie
and then we have an amazing guest who
just joined the panel in the realm
you know in the back door of my man sean
capri from the xbox drive
yo thanks for having me guys this is
awesome i was watching along and
then you guys are jumping in the first
half and i'm like wife wife it's
happening
is like are you sure they know i'm
coming
are you sure i'm like yes
so what we'll do is solve if you don't
mind maybe we just opened it up
for questions everyone for questions
maybe for jazz while we have them here
and it's respectfully under his nda
absolutely so that's before we do that
absolutely that's how
we'll handle this topic um so jazz you
you talked about uh
the how quiet the console is but there
are people in the chat asking about of
course
people want the smoke so if sean murray
with the fight out of superchat asks
please ask
us to address the stupid overheating
rumor of the series x and
of course this stems from where i saw it
was that there was a video from the
giant beastcast
where they were talking about it and and
uh
they touched the console or something
like that and he was like oh my god
it's super hot and apparently you know
the internet ran with it
so what do you say to the heat oh that
the internet
it ran with it are you serious
surprisingly it sounds
so unreal
surprisingly so what do you say to how
the console heats up
um like i say like the the console
itself like i'm just literally
feeling it right now the console itself
[Music]
um
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my god
it's like um it's completely
like cold like the plastic on the
outside
is cold so like i'm i guess like in
the internals sure maybe they're getting
hot but like if you if i crack open my
laptop and
put my finger on the heatsink i'm
probably expecting it
that's what it's meant to be doing but
[Music]
yeah there's heat but go and do that
with your one x go and do that with your
ps4 pro
there is heat so what about your ps4 pro
man it might burn you
did you expand it heat up does it get
warmer yeah it does
he's not like you're not supposed to
talk about that i don't know i don't
care
he's got a matter of already he can't
get it back
the expansion card gets hot as well but
like if
like again if i crack open my laptop and
put my finger on the nvme drive in my
laptop
it's going to be hot the issue is that
like a lot of these people are
unfamiliar with these kind of
high-end components and um just because
it's hot doesn't mean it's breaking
and uh i think some of the other some of
the other you know
fake news that came from this whole you
know people are so desperate to don't
play the xbox series x for some
some reason um someone posted this
a screenshot of um the someone posted a
screenshot of
uh the xbox series x oh actually no it's
the xbox one x is
overheating warning which is what
happens if you if you literally wrap
your console in a
towel you're right and keep the heat
inside it
if you block up all the vents the xbox
will spit out a message that says
um we're shutting down to prevent
overheating
yeah so your device doesn't melt um if
you want to test that yourself
go ahead but don't blame me um stick
stick a towel around your console and
see what happens
you know yeah it might it might turn off
to prevent from overheating well yeah
that
i think i've been really good with that
they um yeah i think they learn
a terrible lesson from the 360. and
anytime
the the system uh feels anything like
any harm
in any way my xbox is shut off and i
noticed i'm like oh okay somebody closed
the deck on uh the door
because i have miners in the in case and
closing so
whenever i'm playing i open my doors up
so it can get uh
ample oxygen inside um the playstation
does the same stuff as well so
you know these these taco developers uh
learned a long time ago
but um one of the fanboy twitter
accounts posted the screenshot of the
xbox one doing that and then said oh my
god
the xbox series x overheats and
influencers aren't allowed to talk about
it
i played monster for like six hours
straight
maybe more and there was no issues to do
with overheating yeah
literally the same way i use my one x
right now my biggest
time stuff like that my biggest question
to you was did you have a heads up that
was coming
and uh okay because it's a double-edged
question so
first did you have a heads up that was
that you were getting one
yes okay so all right so okay the first
my question if you didn't have a heads
up was what was it like when you got the
box
all right now that's that's done um how
did
what was the anticipation like when you
actually got it and then you
opened it up like did it feel like
christmas did you did you have that
uh checking your you're making sure your
your alerts was on your phone
for fedex or whatever that they were
sending it through because i
go through that with my statue so it's
uh
after doing this i've been doing this
now for six seven years
you kind of get kind of get used to it
um
i'm always getting products in this you
know it's part of the job it's part of
the game
and you can't you can't be too much in
your feelings about getting this stuff
because it
you know it affects your objectivity i
can't be like oh my god i'm so excited
to get
xbox series x and then you know and then
like
i don't know you open the box and it
explodes when you plug in or something
like
you can't be like two in your feelings
about this stuff when you're writing
about it and
at the end of the day like yeah i'm
excited i'm an xbox fan and all that but
my real goal is to inform consumers
about whether they're making a
you know a worthwhile choice with their
money and stuff that's
you know we're a tech site at the end of
the day we're not we're not judging the
art of a game we're not
you know you know out here counting
pixels or anything we're a consumer
electronics website at the end of the
day and
my goal and our goal is to inform people
about
how best to spend their money so um i
was aware that it was coming
but i was also aware that it was coming
slower to me than some of the other
press because of
covid's delivery times and i missed the
first delivery because
i don't know was that asleep or
something
i can't remember um i don't know i just
didn't hear the door or something so i
had to wait like
a little bit extra to get get my hands
on it but um
it's the it's the retail unboxing
experience
that influence and press got i don't
know if i'm allowed to say that either
um but uh you know yeah you'll see your
like unboxing videos and down the line
in the future
um but i will say i like it
it's a cool unboxing experience
you guys will see when you get when you
get your hands on it and you you get the
you've seen the retail boxes right there
yes
with the grip right on it wait till you
open that box up man like the what
they've what they've done
with the with the retail packaging is
actually really cool
oh you got the retailer uh
yeah no i thought no because you know
some people were showing
and i'm thinking that it just came in
the ups box just wrapped and it was like
yeah there you go got that
so yeah i don't know if i'm going to say
that but i would i was
i thought you know it's uh people who
are picking it up are in for a cool
unboxing experience
you know that's the whole thing now
unboxing videos and
and stuff like that people showing their
unboxing their stuff on instagram stuff
you know
it's it's a cool one what the what
they've done with it so um
before we get to the next set of
questions let me get these super chats
really quick and then i'll pass it off
to lord sean
um we have lord snowmo black slap with
the ten dollar super chat prayers up for
cogs mom
also love to see the growth success you
guys are having recently it's well
deserved thank you sir
but don't forget tcl got a hit out on
king and jeff
and destiny is still chihuahua dropping
oh my gosh
hello love that super chat love it
then we have sparty on with the 25 super
chat did i say before this party on joe
joined the round around here 25 super
chat from sparty on
just wanted to say thanks for all the
entertainment and info you guys have
provided
since i found the channel thank you
thank you so much
appreciate it and then we have sean okay
sean murray already asked that one then
we have michael askew with the five
dollars
salute to the lords and everyone
registered to vote keep up the amazing
work yes
yes absolutely absolutely then let's put
the crest in the chat for the newest
member of the realm lord
schomberlin that's our guy
for the next step we go that's it pocket
yeah
midday
the world traveler yes yes a little
wandering dutch of them guys yeah where
is he
where is he uh located at because his
his house isn't inside
forza so he's in scotland yeah i thought
i thought charlotte was
and he's in scotland but he teaches uh
uh
uh the asian market uh english yeah
as a second language yeah milan that's
what's up man no doubt no doubt then we
have lord squirrely dan with the two
dollar super chat
cog had to go out west to pick a pick up
from bill
just because i was in washington does it
mean
i was in redmond
but
would you say that the xbox series x is
too much
[Laughter]
[Music]
capri what's up man what's going on man
yes oh not too much
man yeah oh man i'm so i'm so excited
about all this i can't like i'm wrapping
my head around whether or not
uh like this timing for all this news
all this
uh influencer news is like the best
timing or is it kind of
weird right because you can't really buy
one right now right like the timing for
to get to know it and buy it was you
know a couple weeks ago but also like
there's this giant void this giant
vacuum
of news like where playstations is like
you guys go ahead so i can't wrap my
head around like if this is something
and maybe jez want to weigh in on this
as well like is this
beneficial for xbox to take their shot
when there's nothing else going on
or is it opening up an opportunity for
playstation later to go
like this is our our rebuttal this is
our response to everything that that
xbox has been going on
you have to remember microsoft thinks on
a different level to sony
microsoft's like you know we'll announce
our price first we don't care
we'll put our console out to influences
a month ahead we don't care well
not that we don't care it's just that we
are confident in product truth
you know and also that like it's they
don't have to
be so meticulous and secretive because
their their plans extend beyond the
console now they know
for a fact all the xbox hardware that is
manufactured this year
will sell out because neither sony or
microsoft are going to meet demand
so what microsoft is showing here is
confidence in their product
truth which is that it's the most
powerful console
it's you know it's gonna it's the
smaller of the consoles
and they are and potentially has the
most backwards compatibility out of the
box
of the two consoles which is um where
they're putting their focus right now
which is
you know we don't have access to
next-gen games yet
on on the system i presume that uh soon
they might like
you know unlock some of the the launch
games like
assassin's creed or watch dogs or
cyberpunk
maybe i don't know um i don't know what
their plans are for uh
getting closer to launch with the review
units but
um what they're showing is confidence
they're showing confidence in their
product and
you know letting the letting the product
speak for itself at the end of the day
yeah like for me it's kind of like
what what's the deal with the secrecy
around the playstation 5 you know
as a tech reviewer i'm kind of like
it's just it's just strange you know
it's like apple or samsung
yeah i don't know i think it's gonna be
delayed
it was about five or six yeah five or
six sequestered in different ones they
did not see
or have any words with each other and
they said and and make sure you fill out
all the forms properly
or you will not be it was like an escape
room you had to put the playstation in
an escape room
and they had to blow in the controller
to get out oh my god
it's gonna load up man let's get some
levity here
no but it's weird and and everyone gets
a pass this year especially nintendo
japan's been really impacted by
it um bloomberg was reporting that
japanese companies still rely on a
physical
stamp-based approval system and fax
machines and they're not really good
with work from home
but every time sony does something they
step on a rake now really since june
this morning we have the youtube
influencers in japan and they have to
break the news to everyone that sony's
to change their accept button
it's something that i always thought
that microsoft needed to do with japan
um when you're in the menu system they
changed the
it's no it used to be circle was the
accept button in every game now it's
x jazz it's x in japan it's flipped
and if you notice on the switch it's
it's normally flip two
and what's the primary button in games
it's still gonna be the same for now
like all the games they played like the
accept button was still circle and back
was still x
but in the user interface in the
operating system navigating through the
menu
um circle was now back and x was now
accept
which is literally the exact opposite in
japan of what those symbols mean
and not what they've been doing for the
past you know 20 some odd years
right it's a it's also it's a it's a big
thing culturally in japan because i
believe a circle it's huge yeah
circle equals good and then and then
they also went into
some aspects of um besides that as far
as
development stuff so basically instead
of japan having its own separate thing
it's basically now
aligning to the rest of the world right
so i know it's going to be it's going to
hit that region a little hard because
that's
kind of you know what they're used to so
it was an interesting choice the
japanese influencers
like they seem shock shocked like yeah
because i speak shout out to the
nibble on a couple other guys you know
on that region over there they were
saying that they don't expect it to go
very well with japanese players because
they're basically saying you know
obviously you have to unlearn muscle
memory
king you know from the back of the day
when we used to buy imported systems
you know that was something that you
always it was always flip but um
enough of that just wanted to bring that
to it what's what is that does anybody
know what xbox is is xbox b for except
no no they never expect it but i've
never had a uh
imported xbox console yeah yeah so
i wouldn't know uh what would be the
protocols of uh
like moving around in their user face
interface over there
and it would be kind of weird if it was
changed because then you know it like it
throws you off and i'm pretty sure that
people are gonna take an adjustment
period to get used to it
but yeah it's not it's just listen i'm
happy
because i got tired of gotten them
confused it will change
and you will get used to it in the first
couple of days you will be
oh this is kind of weird but it will
become second nature after you done
jumped and
i'm pretty sure i hope they have
something like some type of suspended
play with their games that you can jump
from game to game so that back button
will become
like you know like memory really quick
the sake does playstation 5 and
has playstation 5 not confirmed the sort
of quick resume feature no they haven't
not at all they haven't they haven't
even confirmed the system just stop it
[Laughter]
experience um was there anything that
you
you notice that stood out to you
particularly in terms of uh something
new in the operating system that you can
talk about
well um in the operating system i can't
really talk about anything
in the operating system that's new uh
yet but
one thing that i can tell you about that
surprised me that i didn't think
i'd care so much about um
the shoulder buttons on the new
controller are really really nice
like i don't know if um if you've got an
xbox controller handy
people listening or any of you guys when
you squeeze the shoulder buttons in
there's a bit of flex if you press them
in if you press them in hard there's a
bit of flex
not the triggers not the triggers oh
shoulders right
yeah so if you squeeze them in at the
end there's like a bit of flex in the
plastic
right yes um and that's sort of like
if you in monsters again again i
i experience xbox through the lens of
one sometimes i like 500 i was playing
in this game
but if you if you've got like um a
monster if you're squeezing the shoulder
shoulder button that opens the radial
menu and you have to sort of
use the writing when you and the thumb
stick at the same time and
run while running away from monster it's
like it's hard to get your finger on it
and um sometimes it can slip off
especially if you're using one of the
older controllers
and especially if that plastic flex that
you're feeling
on over time that gets flexier and
flexier that's not a word
it gets more flexible over time because
i think like that's the plastic
wearing down or whatever but on the new
on the new one
um it's like rock hard like that back uh
man what do you call it actuation
actuation on the button is way more
tactile
and uh you know you can just feel it
activating a lot more easily and there's
no
sort of flex in the plastic and uh it
just feels a whole lot nicer the d-pad 2
has been it just feels more tactile on
your thumb
easy to select what you're trying to get
to and all that sort of stuff
so like the the refinements they made to
the controller were one area that i
hadn't really thought about too much
i mean obviously it's like the the big
thing that marketing is the share button
which is useful yes but um it is useful
but the the bigger game changer for me
it was the shoulder button i was like
man this
much better shoulder button on this
thing now are you able to talk about the
share or the sharing to your phone
yeah so sharing to your phone
what is that i don't i don't know if
that's i haven't heard of that feature
is that you mean actually disabled for
him right now
are you talking about the new beta app
which just has the new captures menu or
whatever i don't know somewhere that you
can send a capture to your cell phone so
you can like tweet it out or post on
facebook directly
from your cell phone oh wow oh really
i did not know this um
subscribing right there
that might be um this was about a
planned feature it's supposed to be
linked to your phone
and when you hit the share you're
supposed to be able to go
and send it straight to your phone and
then from your phone you can just shoot
it out to all your social media at one
time
like so whatever platform that you're on
like if you you know
instagram uh facebook uh twitter tic tac
whatever
be able to send that stuff straight up
to it and it's supposed to be something
like
like a real burst mode what it sounds
like to me is they probably have like a
an app that's going to be integrated
like real closely into the system
and when you put something up you'll be
able to click it and share everything
well
you know right now when i'm playing uh
being that all my information is linked
to my phone and my console um anytime i
get on the achievement or whatever
it'll pop up on my phone as well so if
i'm doing something in
uh xcloud or if i'm doing something in
game pass
uh if a new game pass game comes in
it'll pop up on the console
and i can install it from my phone so
they just want the level of flexibility
from all your devices to interact
simultaneously
so if you hit that share it'll shoot to
your phone then you can just shoot it
straight out to
whatever your uh social media of choice
is so
okay i didn't i didn't see that actually
i'm i'm guessing that was an article or
something
um but yeah i can't really talk about
the operating system yet as i say it's
not
it's not a finished it's not the build
that they're pushing out to
retail basically i think there's still
some surprises there
want to keep under wraps for now i think
that i think they're planning to make
some more announcements about
dashboard features and stuff like that
which is why like they're
they're telling everyone like this isn't
this isn't done yet so you know
stay tuned but um are you guys are you
holding onto the console for the
duration and as they
sort of release to you hey you could
talk about this now you can talk about
this now
is that how it's basically working out
where you hold up yeah that's how it's
working out yeah
it's like um it's sort of like over time
uh
all new updates come and then new
features get lit up and new games come
and stuff like that
it's it's it's very weird i've never had
a product a month ahead of it's launched
before
i think i think what it is uh jazz is
they got so much that they want to show
to the community and to
you know the xbox uh consumer and
consumer in general
that uh you know they they want to show
so much but they don't want it all
coming out at once they you know they
well you got a certain around you could
talk about this and it feels like right
now
the highlight for the uh you know the
journalists and people in the press
right now is
we want you to show how well we've done
backwards compatibility and then
probably next week it's something else
they're going to open up something else
that you're
able to talk about i mean i have to say
man you know they started out messaging
great obviously when they launched it
when they
first spoke about the console and phil
talked about it at the game awards and
then
when they were talking about the games
people felt like you know it was a
little spooky
in the way that they spoke about the
games that were coming to the console
but then like ever since then they've
sort of righted the ship in that regard
and
i think this sort of you know piece by
piece sort of breakdown of what the
console can do
um i think it's fantastic because you
get you're never
you're never going to be without
information right you'll be talking
about something for a week and a half
two weeks maybe
and then the next feature drops or
whatever and it's it's it's genius
really because
they wanted people to really highlight
on you know
what an uncapped frame rate on some of
these games could do so what do they do
instead of giving you know the media all
the backwards compatible games
like we unlock everything that doesn't
do that so you got to talk about that
so microsoft's really they they're doing
this very well
yeah i think like it's funny because
someone said earlier will this give sony
a chance to counter
quite honestly i think that microsoft
has done it this way because
they're they want to highlight things
that they think
the playstation might not have down very
well
like for example the fact that sony
hasn't really
been transparent about how much
backwards compatibility is coming to
playstation
it's kind of telling to me and like as
someone who plays a lot of service games
that
aren't getting next-gen upgrades at
launch like overwatch for example
is over what's going to be their day one
we don't know is minecraft going to be
there on day one
microsoft hasn't said it's it's kind of
you know concerning like
when when it comes to xbox all those
games are going to be there because it's
basically the same system but with
upgrades
but the playstation it's set the fact
that like saves don't transfer and stuff
like that
it sounds like there might be developer
work that has to be done in order to
bring those games across
and if that's the case which developers
are going to support playstation on day
one which of them are going to be like
oh well we're doing
this at the moment we'll come back to
this later you know so
i think like in the in the fact that
microsoft's highlighting backwards
compatibility right now
it's it's part of their messaging that
like yeah your games will be there all
of them
on day one and yeah the ones that have
dynamic features will have
announcements you know what's crazy too
jazz is is
uh the biggest question people want to
see is they want to see how assassin's
creed von gaal
games like that run on the system and
like for the most part everyone that has
this system is going to get that game as
a review copy because it's the media
so i have a feeling that that's the last
thing they're like
talk about the launch titles now like a
week before the game comes out until the
system comes out
yeah for sure maybe sure yeah just just
mentioned something about that just
totally triggered something like does
microsoft have like a trojan horse into
the back end of what's happening for
next gen on the sony end
by publishing minecraft on playstation
like
as a software developer as somebody who
puts a game on a playstation being
minecraft
like do they get a sense maybe what is
happening like
they have like a little spy in there you
[Music]
i don't know i mean that's the funny
thing though right like not necessarily
on purpose as a snitch but if you're
great if there are issues
they probably are aware of that i mean
jim dan's moves ryan is compliant he's
compliant
he's already he's already been
assimilated i mean i mean to be honest
with you this is
not him dance moves a problem right this
is like no this is
a mark certainly like i this is a mark's
journey like he made another ps3
type listen this the pro this is the
problem right this is what happens when
you allow the competitors game on your
hardware you must give your specs up so
we can make your game work and run
what he expects so now you know why they
was always a step ahead with hardware
they knew your specs
it was not even like a little game
either it's kind of a big deal minecraft
and we have millions of subscribers it
was like epic coming out with uh with
fortnite and
using uh
shut up shut up they got epic
[Music]
i'll give you a little bit of insider
industry knowledge here both sony and
microsoft
know each other's systems yeah like
it's like especially sony in the game
like that they they know what each other
has because not only like
they talk to other publishers and stuff
and like if you know ubisoft knows what
the playstation is they're going to tell
microsoft
if ea knows what the xbox is they're
going to tell sony it's just
it's just like it's just the way that
goes like
at a certain level the information is
just out there for everyone to
know about so yeah microsoft didn't know
about the system but so
sony knew about the experts yeah it's
only knew about microsoft they just
didn't have the pockets to go change
they switched them around
and that's when the money is different
over here
[Laughter]
so first off we have a regulator 951
with the two dollars so we chat
good morning lords easy on the bone
cream chest
[Laughter]
crazy right then we have safe space
invader with the five dollars of attack
i know right thank you guys jess i got
one question
uh uh in your merch do you have a bone
cream shirt
i will i would like to buy a bone cream
shirt
it's uh it's funny you ask that you know
because um
we're trying to figure out because uh
cult eastwood shout out to the caller
yeah he makes a lot of our channeling
modes for rand's channel and windows
central
gaming channel as well and um we're
trying to figure out how to make a bone
cream emote
that's sort of safe for work
so i got you i already i really
had already see it
[Music]
that's too subjective you have to take
it all the way and i'm not going to say
it because i want i want him to you know
so i will tell them in the dms but is is
is very simple
and and it is effective and it's not
offensive and
it is very nice moving on from boldly
let's go
we go back to safe space invader
we have uh jez are you playing the
series x on an hdmi 2.1 tv with vrr
if so did vrr work i play on the lg c9
with vrr and it makes a big difference
sadly no um i uh i don't
have it's not so much it's not even so
much the space although i mean the money
it's the space like i don't british
houses like
up north they were built during the
victoria victorian era a lot of the time
and some of these like terraced houses
they're not designed
for 55-inch tvs so like
the issue i've got is finding a 48-inch
at most
tv that supports these features they
just don't exist the c10
um do you have the c10 has a 48 inch
version
a c10 yeah does it yeah c10 yeah see
they all lets you get me i'll be
speaking to all months about it as an
option well i was like i was looking at
the diamond
television but um when i was looking
brand on your television jazz
i'm using the samsung culin no no i just
wanted to know the brand name that's it
yeah he just wanted to share
[Laughter]
come on man
i think we answered that already
regulator yes can you debunk all this
overheating nonsense yeah we did that
yeah it's debunked um then we have
gaming forte with the 10
super chat i think slo-mo has it wrong
first
why hate on a game that you don't play
your analogy is backwards
destiny is the chihuahua and division is
the dropping get him
get him
i think i'm going to ban all this
destiny talk from here on out
hold on we got a few other uh
oh yeah izzy we have dizzy coming up we
have dizzy with the two dogs super chat
sia san diego studio has xbox series x
dev kit for the show
um yeah that makes sense let me get hr
obama so
day job forgive what was on he says
all access no access tcl oled
it's coming this is our resident tcl uh
representative h.r obama
so he's riding for the cause and salute
to him he's actually had an issue with
um all
access we try to see what's going on
he's been having a lot of problems i
think if you pre-order with all access
there's been some issues so try to get
to the bottom left actually microsoft
addressed this and they said uh i guess
this coming week
if you manage to get a console into your
cart
through all access and then you couldn't
do it yeah they're going to be emailing
you
so that you can have an opportunity to
actually finish that purchase so
thank you they said they set aside
consoles specifically for that so
i don't know who did it's gonna actually
get but i got two of them
yeah no doubt then we got a jw jw with
the 10
super chat i disagree with sony knowing
microsoft specs otherwise sony wouldn't
wouldn't have overclocked uh geez
i still want credit for the bone cream
any royalties bro i want half i want
half
hatties
[Laughter]
so listen we got the job i want to ask a
question so yeah jazz man i mean
obviously you got a chance um the two
questions i have for you
is one as a switch guy you said some
things on the xbox two with ran
that really resonated which is the share
button you know as
we know right now the way it currently
stands you know you got to press the
xbox live button
you know you gotta press why it's so
unintuitive the way xbox currently does
their share system
so for mine from my understanding what
you said is now that share button
is a quick tap immediately from the
controller you can get that screenshot
and then is it a hold like the nintendo
switch where you can get the video
on the on the um can we talk about that
okay yeah it works exactly i don't know
if i can talk about it but
oh sorry i i don't know if they're gonna
they're probably not gonna change this
so i don't know why
i don't know why i wouldn't be able to
talk about it um but yeah it works the
same way as switch you tap it to take a
screenshot
you long press it to take a clip and if
you double tap
it um it opens up your recent captures
so you can like find what you want to
share and that sort of thing
so it works it works well it's super
intuitive it's instant because the cpu
is better
um so i think like if you share a lot of
kit
clips and stuff like that you're gonna
be pleased with the way microsoft
set up this system awesome and part two
of my question was
quick resume you know um my i guess
again if you can talk about it you know
having something i can talk about
nice oh the three to four games you know
at a time
you know how how much of a game change
is it because
again i know coming from a pc and nvme
you know
setup i know getting into a game that's
one thing
but to be able to switch a game leave
your progress where it is between three
or four different games
seems i just can't wrap my mind around
it so listen to you talk about i just
wanted to get more
details on your feeling of that
experience
it's uh it's it's weird right because
like i said on um i said this on xbox
too but
i've had to sort of um
change my my gaming habits a bit because
um one of the things that i uh
i always do on xbox is i hard close my
games because
the current quick resume feature on the
xbox one sometimes
leaves you with these like weird issues
in certain games
and i think that's because there's some
developer input that has to happen to
make quick resume work smoothly
i don't know if a game has to be built
certain way or something like that and
again if there's any developers
listening maybe they can enlighten us
but some games work really well with
xbox one's quick
quick resume for one game and other
games just don't and they break
and rather than find out if my game is
broken because of quick resume i just
don't use it
right so i just like hard close my games
like i always hard close monster until
like out of habit and stuff like that
however um it feels like the new system
doesn't require any developer input
because every game i've tested with
works completely flawlessly which is
like really cool to see
um like obviously there are games where
you can um you have to like
log out and stuff if you're not around
bro
right so i think like an online game
like destiny yeah for example
yeah like it's always online game yeah
continue just i'm sorry yeah so like um
in destiny for example uh if you're not
logged in for a while you will get
disconnected like so um fast fast resume
for that developers as a developer is
making an online game might have to
tweak it a bit like how uh monster works
where like you just go into offline mode
if you
if you're not in the game or whatever um
but uh but yeah for games where either
you don't get disconnected like monster
hunter or an offline game like ori or
something like that
you just literally it's as if the game
was just frozen in time
like not it doesn't even open a pause
menu or anything like that
like for example if you pause minecraft
dungeons
the second before you get hit by a
creeper for example
you will come back to that game and
you'll get hit by that creeper so like
you might want to if you if you're going
to do the whole quick resume thing you
might want to
be like careful about when you do it
yeah yeah um but
it works flawlessly it's uh you know
no complaints on how it works that i've
seen and uh the only the only problem is
getting into the habit of actually using
it because like i say
i'm so used to just closing my games
that i'm like oh man i could just quick
resume that why didn't i do that
right so well if you don't close your
now like it kind of
impacts your internet connection as well
like if i've got call of duty running in
the background i'm gonna go download a
new game
like the speed isn't gonna be there so i
usually have to go in and close i'm
curious if you've tested anything like
that if you try to
download anything with things in quick
resume that it seems like it's a
completely separate
separate thing where if a game you're
running in the background or saved in
quick resume it's not going to impact
that
yeah it's it is a completely different
thing it's
awesome it's like i say i think it's i
think this is completely
system-led it's not like developer led
so a developer doesn't have to have any
input
and i think the way microsoft have done
it is it because of the ssd
and i don't know i really really don't
understand the technical wizardry behind
how this was even possible but from what
i understand is it works similarly to
how like
you know like on android for example
when like you
quick resume an app the app just goes
into a suspended state
and like it's and like depending on your
settings it stops using all internet
stops using all background power and
stuff like that i don't know how it
works but
it works the same way i think it's just
like a full-blown
suspension of whatever game you had
running and uh
so if uh if you're worried about it
using internet or power while
you know it's um uh suspended i don't
know
i don't think i don't think it does and
then what about before it happens
a lot of these multiplayer games too
like if if you stand by for
even a couple minutes they they kick you
out to them
yeah and can you manage can you manage
them too jazz can you go like if i
wanted one game like always in quick
resume like how do you know when
which ones are like maybe one's gonna
get booted out if you could put one
another game
on quick resume is there like a a queue
and can you like lock something in i
didn't see anything on the ui when
they're running through it they're like
this game is gonna
is currently being suspended in quick
resume
no it just it just works like you just
just like
um if you just go hit the dashboard
you'll just
it just it'll work it just automatically
goes into quick resumes stuff like that
you don't have to do anything magical to
make it work
um but those games that do have like a
disconnection timer i guess like
for example if you if you're in the
middle of a match in overwatch or call
of duty
you'll hit the you'll hit the idle timer
and get kicked out of the match
but when you quick resume you'll just be
like at the lobby or something like that
so it's not like it's not like you have
to load up the whole game again
i guess what i'm worried about is if i
put too many games into quick resume
that like
it can't it can't keep them all like
when do i know that one is going to be
kicked out of quick resume
in that night right yeah
there is there is a hard limit i don't
know what it is off the top of my head
um but there as far as i'm aware there's
no there's nothing right now that tells
you if a game is
um being slipped out of quick results
as far as i'm aware there's no system to
manage quick resume but
that might be one of the things that
they're keeping under wraps for the
future updates and stuff i have it on
good authority that there's still a lot
of
there's they've got lots of plans for
this operating system because now they
have the cpu
to match their ambitions right so
even if like a lot of those features
right now
aren't there i completely expect
microsoft will reopen the uh
feedback hub for ideas and stuff and
we'll probably see like loads of new
little features that just weren't
possible back in the day
like you remember like we used to have
snap mode and picture in picture and
stuff like that
they strip yeah they strip those
features out because
the the xbox one was so starved for
resources
i had to do stuff like that to like get
the the basics up to speed like just the
general speedy operating system
had to type priority over those features
yeah but now that we
allocate ten percent to connect connect
yeah
yeah exactly but now we've got like more
modern
cpu let's say and a very very fast ssd
there are things that they can do that
they just weren't able to do before so i
wouldn't
be surprised
you know there's a segment of the
community in the gaming community i
believe the ssd and xbox is slow
that's certainly an interesting take i
wonder what the speed of the ssd on
their computers is
i don't know right they don't have one
oh my god yeah
let's get this super so before we get
these super chats though i'm gonna drop
something in the chat
so you guys get ready to with them with
those fingers
go get it go go get it get it bone cream
exactly
that is an xbox code for those who don't
know it's an xbox code and
it is in celebration of microsoft's
acquiring xenomax studios it is the
arcane collection which
includes wow dishonored they saw her
death of the outsider
um something else i think so it is a
number of
uh arcane games in this nice salute
go get that go get that all right let's
go let's get these super chats that we
are relying on
um we have good jd gamer with the five
dollar switch
good morning lords jazz great show yeah
have drunken ninja with the two dollars
could be chat time on the bone cream
please
he was affected by that he liked the
conversation
i want to see that emoji
i love jazz
so many memes coming out of xbox two now
like yes
right every day right rand's like dm and
me like oh my god what have you done now
filmic random tomato ball creamer
classics
i was just chilling playing some uh nms
what is that no man's sky no match guys
and i got a and i gotta hear the slander
from people that never got past level 10
or 20 division
shaking my head on a game you haven't
really played
salute to the division lords in their
referendum
and we got smitty smith with the five
dollar super chat destiny 2 the drifter
oh
you're bringing a lie detector
hold on let me get elemental power with
the files in the chat i hear the ps5 ssd
has
less usable memory allocation for games
has jazz ever seen the five heartbeats
night like this
savage very savage very savage
you gotta just look up uh nights like
this five heartbeats on youtube
youtube
uh then we have eagles 76 it's the five
dollars image
deads have you used old controllers on
series x and if so do they need to
update for low latency
finally do you think uh you remap the
share button on the elite two
yes um i did remap the the share button
on the elite two and actually i'm still
using the elite series two as my main
controller
even though like i was talking about how
great the shoulder points were
i just the the charge dock on the elite
series 2 is just so damn confusing
so um but yeah uh the
my series 2 didn't pick up an update um
i think a lot of the
auto low latency stuff oh and this goes
back to um
someone else's question about using 2.1
hdmi features
um which i didn't fully answer either so
auto low latency
mode it's like what it does is the tv
will
hdmi with hdmi 2.1 the tv will detect
that there's a console connected
and will automatically switch your tv
into game mode which is
more responsive than tv mode which
prioritizes
picture quality and and stuff like that
where you don't you don't need inputs to
navigate netflix menu for example
but like on when you're playing a
console you want to have like the
fastest response time possible
for your controller and stuff like that
so it they'll set that feature
automatically
like sometimes i dread how many people
out there i've got playstations and
switches
and um xbox is plugged into a 4k tv
and they don't have game mode turned on
can you imagine how many people
out there do that probably a lot of
people very impressed
yeah probably a lot of tco users
oh my god you know we're going to get a
cease and desist with the ttl
i downloaded squadrons last night can't
wait to play i i actually downloaded it
as well haven't played it yet
i uh definitely want to play that um
shout out to thor he's playing that game
like there's no tomorrow
then we got uh jd is jade up as a
showtime chat over 500 in the chat
smash that like button salute brother oh
lord jb golden i i in the chat i just
gave you my twitter
so you can just get at me and i can get
you that stuff um then we have victor
brick gaming with the five dollars
i like that name i like that if power
goes out in the house does quick resume
cash
cash or get wiped or will those games
still be there when power comes back on
i heard that if you could hard you could
turn off the console like yeah
and then i actually um i haven't tested
that yet but i've i've heard that is
indeed the case that the
that at least for a certain amount of
time like
many hours we're talking that it will
keep those
games suspended in the ssd memory i
haven't tested it myself yet but that's
on my list of things to test
manage it i'm sorry i need like i need
like four i need a four person team here
to do all my work for me
i'm uh i'm struggling frankly
i'm about to hire victor brick um to go
collect my knees
um because they're going to name like
vic the brain
who's at the door it's victor brick
and i'm here for your knees
salute to the lords for the geeks in the
room microsoft is using virtual machines
for back compact
quick resumes are snapshots amazing
implementation
absolutely and we have the wise old
gamer with the two
people chat is bone cream cheaper or
better better for me versus my blue pill
wise old game
[Laughter]
from all age demographics and questions
for maximum effects
to go through to hit the game on button
game on all right
[Laughter]
yeah i got him right here jw follow
super chat
jazz why do our brothers across the pawn
say
h h as and not h oh
yeah yeah it's a hdmi hdmi
talk what do you guys say
h yeah he's like he's like what the heck
he's like baffled i love this i love
this one
talk like oh okay yeah yeah
like oh yeah okay i gotta decide now um
because we invented the language i could
say what i want [ __ ]
i i i just i really really
really enjoyed that that get on my level
yeah i like that getting
the originators of this that was that
was very british that was very dramatic
and i love it
was that after the wise old gamer
because i i still got more too
yeah i know slow mo back flap is next
yeah if this is after the watch
you may have it on top chat take it to
the live chat no it's uh it's on live
and it's not everything
for me before we refresh i got him i got
him slow mo back slab ten dollar super
chat
forte is a fraud i have days in destiny
it's still dumpster juice they still
battling about
he was playing control but got exposed
for only having 0.3
hours in it three weeks hashtag i'm
better
i'm the better half of the dps podcast
oh my god will you guys stop
rivalry going
i currently have an oled v6 and when i
put the tv on game mode
it really washes out the color so i
really had to adjust it
yeah i kind of know what you mean yeah i
didn't like it turn that
off those tvs are good enough do not
they have a response mode for the uh the
lg's as well but you don't have to
actually
do all that but i'll i'll talk to them
later about that eagles fan 76 tonight
we check how fast does randolph tomato
load can it do
4k 120. wow all right
i got i got them after three reloads i
got it uh we have iron mike
with the two dollars does disabling
quick resume free up ssd space
um i actually i saw austin evans say
that you could disable quick resume
i don't know if that feature's actually
in yet to disable crooked zoom
and if it is i couldn't find it so i
think that might be something that maybe
he either he has access to because he's
on a more advanced build because he's
like
you know super cool um and uh
i don't have access to a because i'm
lame but um
or if it's a feature that's coming later
or what
or he's just heard it or he's been told
that it that it will be the case
i imagine that if um if indeed you can
turn it off and i
you know i don't see any reason why he
would get that wrong
i imagine that yeah it would free up
some space on the ssd
but i think the xbox is dynamic like
that i think like if you want to install
a game it's not going to be like oh
sorry you've got quick resume enabled
you can't do this
i think it'll probably like just be like
you know if you
want to install this be aware that we
can only quick resume
like four games instead of five or
whatever it is i don't know yet
as i say the operating system's not
finished well it is finished but we
don't have access to it or whatever
it's uh because they they want us to
test specific things i think
yeah yeah i think like every week like
attic is on onto something
uh every week uh you know get a new
feature list that uh
comes out and y'all can talk about x y
and z going forward and you know do your
videos and stuff like that
i think they want to be at the beginning
of the information cycle which starts on
monday
and ends on a friday um you know like
cog and i was talking around in the
background yeah and we said on uh
midweek mix-up
good news is released on monday bad news
released on friday so
the bad news is the playstation
information came out on the weekend
oh my god we know it was bad now
sony believes in generations save
generations gym dance moves ryan
says they will unlock cross saves if 500
people hit that filmic like button
just wanted to say hi i just ate a
tomato and i'm kind of worried that i
ate randa on accident and now
i don't get
no no no um um pretty much uh i asked
him everything because i
pretty much know what he can't talk
about so and
uh i i understand that like a week
before you just recently got yours right
uh yeah i man time is like
become this sort of abstract concept for
me i can't even remember which day i got
it
okay so you just recently got yours and
people together
yeah prior to you they had a limited
amount of games
uh for backup and i think uh austin evan
explained that 300 games was released
the following week
and uh he assumes like uh weekly they
will be releasing more so i don't know
how long he was in the program
and stuff like that oh let me ask you a
question i do have one question um
when when i'm playing my game pass they
have i like a little checklist right and
they give you like little goals to hit
to move to the next tier is it something
like that with you guys in this program
that you have to do
x amount of functions to be able to move
on to the next amount of functions or is
everything just open to you
and it's like have at it yeah
everything's everything's open
it's just like that that wouldn't
dictate to press like how to approach
their coverage
go um it's it's just a case of like
when the operating system updates you
know i presume i presume we're in a
similar ring to
maybe like external testers maybe like
uh
retail marketing reps and stuff like
that because um
you know salesforce presumably will have
access to
the consoles now and you know people who
like
you know researching the console so they
can sell them to their customers
down the line and stuff like that so i i
think it's just a case of that really i
don't think like
it's uh there's going to be any special
requirements before yeah because the
more features
a lot of times people are uh believing
that you guys are under some form of the
rest
and you have to answer in a manner uh
they just want you all to be truthful
and honest of your experience
with the console and you can just put it
out in that manner right
that's pretty much how i'm getting it
that's pretty much like i really like
working with microsoft because like
they just they don't they don't try and
be overly controlling with any of their
embargoes or anything this is this goes
true for like surface and
everything and stuff like that i gave um
like i had the surface duo phone out to
influencers pretty early as well
um so they could write their reviews and
you know so there was some pretty harsh
feedback about that phone
um but you know microsoft takes it as
like well
you know this is this is real world
feedback and we need to improve on it
they can afford to not be so controlling
i guess
um is ultimately what it is and uh let
the product speak for yourself
it just all speaks of like the
confidence we're talking about earlier
right
so so so okay so you said something and
i'm a keen on in on that
you said they can afford to be this uh
uh like free with it uh so you mean
other companies can't be that free
because financially they can't afford to
do this right i'm just messing with you
i'm not necessarily talking about this
don't answer that leave that alone
[Laughter]
get a step away from that step away from
me
seriously do you remember like um i
remember metal gear solid five's review
boot camp i don't know if you guys heard
about this
yeah but like the work for those who
don't know the way metal gear solid five
phantom pain reviews worked was
they flew out a bunch of high high level
journalists
to um are you not me i flew a bunch of
high-level journalists to uh review the
game
sitting in a hotel room or whatever with
two konami
press guys standing over there oh no
like
yeah seriously like um explaining the
game i also had access to cheats like
god mode and stuff like that
so they could skip through the story
more quickly and uh it just wasn't
it wasn't how a consumer would
experience that day oh so you know like
just like what just happened this
weekend where they locked them all off
into this
question room so they haven't learned
this thing
again i have no idea what's happening
i'm just messing with you just
don't follow me down this rabbit hole
man listen i don't want anybody to
associate you with my crap just leave me
alone
in the
anybody uh addict gene or showing any
final questions for jessica
before he goes no not really okay cool
i mean pretty much he's answered
everything i have to offer yeah i'm good
all right cool lord sure wanna make sure
you got everything yeah no man i'm just
stoked about it i can't wait nice
yeah man lord this is fantastic i'm
super pumped i mean
we're a month away man i cannot wait to
get my hands on this thing
and like i said all these amazing
features nvme quick resume
you know just the raw compute of natural
back compact without even being
optimized and even patched yet
is so impressive so when those patches
come and those things happen
you know in the future it's going to be
even more impressive but salute to you
man you guys are killing it
so look the window central out here
killing it man
love what you guys do super proud of
course the xbox too man you're killing
it
tell the people where they can find you
man unlike the other things you got
going on before
you roll out yeah so uh you know follow
uh
rand's channel random score al on the
score thor
underscore 19 i wish he had a better
brand
but um that's where we do our podcast
you can go to xbox 2 on soundcloud and
find all the external links
or follow me on twitter at jscordenjzydn
and uh yeah thanks for having me guys i
love doing this podcast you guys are a
laugh right every single time so
you know thanks for your hard work for
the community and all that stuff thanks
for having me and i really do appreciate
you taking the time out of your day
because i know especially right now
for the stuff that you do because of the
they're calling
i was just five months onto the whole
podcast
when you say that on xbox you're doing
you're doing the uh the random
just joining random people not doing the
mic communication and just killing a
beast
pretty much yeah you're the people i
hate it on
twitter monsters is an amazing twitter
follower
i love him brother thank you for
spending the time as always thank you
brother
get your time man you already know
that's what we got
next moving along as as lord jess
alluded to
uh there's a little messiness with
s4 the ps5 saves a little muddiness
we didn't introduce sean yeah we did it
we did it but it was very minor because
we were
introducing jess let's let's get
stronger he has a great display in the
background
and i just really i really love when
he's on the road
let me click let me click his name so
you can see his back yes
man i already clicked his name i was
looking at his stuff the whole time
here yo his displays look amazing yeah
you pack them so
nice oh man that's nice man
but that's really that sweet i like the
stainless steps in the back though
yeah you see this yeah
yeah they're nice i'm like i'm not going
to put them on my feet or nothing
i've never touched you since i put these
here i'll never get them back looking
that good there yeah man like they're
i want to just drop my pin
they're my size too like they asked me
for my size and everything like that's
they're nice dude they're
really nice dan smith is an old gym
man aaron shout out to great work
yeah i had a pin on there too yeah dude
yeah i'm so lucky man like i'm just
living the life right now it's awesome
greenberg's name all over it he's a
sneaker head man
oh my god i had to look up like on like
uh instagram like how do you how do you
display shoes i don't know how to do
this i would have just been like like
straight up
that side profile brother that's right
you did it good you did a good yeah
i won't even try now but that's it well
the embarrassing part is this is my
professional office
like when i work this is my zoom call so
well
like come on in come on into my home and
i just like absolutely get it over with
take a picture you know and then we'll
get back to business here but
yeah man this is it this is my office
gotta respect it man yeah so of course
sean capri on the xbox drive also the uh
cup of joe and nintendo with uh our good
friend the nintendo girl right
yes and my favorite we the gamer cast
which i was proud to be a part of
you know what i'm saying so salute to
you and all that but um yeah we're going
to talk about these topics man uh what's
going on and i'll jump it off
with my topic with the um you know
what's going on with the the save
situation with playstation 5.
and um you know it first came out i
believe with a yakuza like a dragon
uh which is actually coming out to both
platforms so it looks like they had made
a statement
this was on the 28th of september and
they said just to clarify
the physical owners of yakuza like a
dragon on ps4
can also use their original disk to
upgrade to the playstation 5
when it releases on march 2nd 2021 so
that we learned at that point
i guess yakuza like a dragon is a timed
exclusive for the series x
first but then the second part they go
save data will not be
transferable between the playstation 4
and playstation 5
versions of the game so that kind of
wrote raise an eyebrow so okay maybe
it's an individual
you know situation but then you know we
got some news from codemasters who
create
dirt which is dirt 5 that's coming out
next gen and then they made a statement
they said currently on xbox all progress
can be carried over between generations
but on playstation your playgrounds
correct creations can be carried over
but other game progress career currency
save deliveries cannot
if that changes we'll let you know
so this was going around twitter um
immediately it seems like
xbox kind of smell blood because aaron
greenberg put out a tweet
and he's like cost cloud saves and four
generations of compatibility
means i pick up right where i left off
and he starts going into
you know having quick resume and save
data and save progress
going on from the x or from the xbox one
to the xbox series
x so look i want to bring this to the
realm you know we don't know what's
going on looks like uh eurogamer
tried to reach out for playstation for
comment you know they have their own
uh opinions on what it might be i don't
know if it's a cross generation support
or a cloud issue
but i wanted to bring this to the realm
what do we think
is going on with save data features from
ps4 to ps5
let's start with gene though let's get
let's get g popping
um the first thing that i noticed is i
don't think that they're being entirely
transparent about yakuza
on the xbox on the series
x site of the
smart delivery there are no next-gen
features it's not
listed when i checked last month it's
not 4k
there's no hdr it's not 60 frames per
second
so i i don't believe that we're getting
the series
x version of that game this year uh and
i i wish they were being a little bit
more transparent about that because
they're you know sony's putting on some
bad news but microsoft's
not putting out really being you know a
straightforward answer to what it is
and maybe at launch maybe on the 10th we
are going to get the series
x version of the game that is 4k is hdr
it looks like the ps5 version is going
to be a significant graphical
upgrade with uh different character
models so
i i'm not really sure what's going on
with that but yeah sony's got a
sony's got a problem with saves that
they got to address and i wish they had
someone
in the communities like aaron greenberg
or really anybody
that that could take what's take the
feedback that's going on on twitter
online on social media
and translate that back to them right
now there's nobody doing that and
they're dead silent about it it's really
it's problematic uh so hopefully they
can address
some games can have saves move over and
some games can't
so it sounds like a developer issue but
sony's got to work with them and help
them
get that through so they don't have you
know mud in their face
during this long yeah it's interesting
i'm just trying to
be curious guess i'm sorry you know it
it really is kind of
weird i mean i guess if there's if
there's a right way to handle it is
don't talk about it until you have
something to say
so if even even if the perception is
like if the perception is well there's
something wrong
um so yeah that does kind of work me a
little bit as we get into
you know what what's coming out for
launch that we may not have the series x
versions of a lot of these games
it wasn't the topic that sony saves how
did we get over here oh
you know what happened wait a second it
always happens with
with a playstation xbox you're like okay
let's talk about the thing that sony
dropped the bond yeah but xbox
my point was i don't believe that yakuza
is going to have a series s version of
the game on the 10th that's just my
opinion sure
sure sure i don't mean to i don't mean
no no no we'll move to the lord capri
since he wants that smoke for that place
i love what king does man i got all over
this now because
it's like it's such a the inconveniences
are adding up to me
you know and i like my my time is
limited for gaming like a lot of us and
i just look at xbox and it's just so
easy and a lot of us who upgraded from
the one to the one x
like i imagine it's gonna be a very
similar experience going on to the
series x where you just like
same chords you just unplug one and you
plug the other one in and you don't even
have to think about it like i don't want
to have to dick around with this stuff
anymore so i just don't even have to
consider it with xbox it's
it's ridiculous and it just it's amazing
the number of passes and by the way
i have my my gears uh xbox one x sitting
next to my spidey ps4 pro next to my
switch i have them all
and i feel like that's even silly to
have to say if you have a criticism of
one of the camps
you have kind of to say like i had four
playstation fours as jen
like i put enough money to say things
about playstation right you know what i
mean
so that that that's one thing so the
whole like the save thing is just
ridiculous and to me it's just i don't
want to have to deal with that garbage
that kind of sucks yeah i know what's
going on
and why do you want to tell the truth
for saying the devil but i do
yes um what's going on sir we believe
that jim dance moved ryan believes in
generations
so yes save is in the last generation
if you want your saves to cross over go
play
the last generation pretty much is that
that's
fresh you know we want to fresh slate
yeah see now y'all thoughts
fresh slates started with the
playstation 5 and
all those games will only be available
there no no no no see what with jim
dance moves ryan was telling you
we believe in generations so
generationally you won't be playing over
here
in this generation believe in
generations if you want to go to the
past generation you can also go to the
other room and play your playstation 4
and be in that generation so done
i think there'll be a time where it
matters less right i think there will be
like three four years from now it'll
matter
right right now big time because limited
amount of space
so i think it really is a space issue
see everybody thinks is
you can't be bringing all your saves
over here oh willy nilly
and there's only 600 gigs i mean like
you're going to tear up
with all that you know all that memory
so i thought you meant space on your
table because you have to you're gonna
have to get rid of your playstation
because you're
playing
you know you could house it in your shed
outside maybe and then have the cord
coming on in
oh my god it's huge it's huge
[Laughter]
and um
[Music]
i'm a huge yakuza fan i've owned i own
all the acoustic games in every region
i can't wait to get that game on the
10th and on the 12th i'm putting that
game in my playstation 5
and maybe i play there's going to be
we're going to play 100 games that we
don't
maybe i play it for three or four hours
and then march 2nd or march 5th whatever
i put that same exact game in my
playstation 5.
is it going to load the playstation 5
version of that game and it's not going
to work or my save is going to be gone
like what happened
you're going to buy the playstation 4
version and put it in your playstation 5
it's backwards compatible so you can buy
the ps4 version put in the ps5
because then what happens on march 2nd
it's not going to work
that's not the list okay so
they got a list of 100 games and out of
100 games out of the best playlist that
game went on it so
you buy the playstation 5 version if
you're going to buy it on that day
just to be safe the playstation 5
version accuser does not come out until
march search
so then wait till march
and this is the thing this is sony's
problem they're saying that the game is
backwards compatible but what happens on
march 2nd when i get that free upgrade
the playstation 5 version is my save
gone
that's a good question the way it was
wording it
like now you know not for jokes you know
okay okay so okay
forget all the jokes you're real serious
about it because this is something that
you've been playing like you said you've
been playing that series all the way
through right
yeah and your hopes and and your dreams
is to you want to purchase this game
and this is a serious question we joke a
lot all right i joke a lot but he's
really serious right now
so then he wants to buy this game
his concern is all that work that he's
going to put into this game
in march when he gets all his bells and
whistles that he's going to par he's
going to
mark it on his calendar that day that
the bells and whistles are supposed to
be added he wants his bells and whistles
but he wants his save to go over
and this is the true concern from a sony
playstation dude
who's not getting his questions answered
and i really feel like i kind of really
messed up
that you don't have the answers and you
still are willing to purchase
and look for this march date that's kind
of violent
it's going to directly imp sorry sorry
it's going to directly impact me because
we have to play all the games that come
out for launch for on both consoles
so i'm not going to be able to play
through that game that week or that
month i am going to be playing it come
march
right that's crazy i think it goes back
to what jez was talking about how
while using the series x it's obvious
that everything just happens
on the console level and it requires
nothing from the devs
everything all that stuff happens on the
console level it's just there
and it's a natural progression for what
we've already seen with the with the
with the
you know the 1x the xbox one family of
consoles
so it's it's kind of disturbing to me
that it feels like
once again you know i i see this
scenario and it reminds me sort of a
playstation 3
where it's like it seems like they've
created a console on an island
and not thinking about the fluidity of
the ecosystem and
it just and i don't know that i don't
know this to be true but everything we
sort of glean from everything that we've
heard so far it seems that that is the
case
and it's just it's weird to me man it's
hard to do
it's hard to do i think it just goes to
show like how great xbox is at this
because it's way easier to just go like
the other one's left behind it's harder
to build this interconnected ecosystem
absolutely 100 it is and that but i but
being that you're looking to do this
right being that my feeling is that it's
always from the beginning of of this
eighth generation of consoles
that was always the plan moving forward
so it's only not
not so sort of be prepared for that or
like they're not prepared for that is
very strange to me
even still going the route of you know
exclusives matter uh you know
we big budget triple a games this is the
route that we're going even if you're
still going that route and not even
thinking about services and things like
that
in the way that microsoft is it's the
fluidity of ecosystem and
and how your boxes talk to one another
pause um is
is is essential and it's just so strange
to me that it feels like
when i talk about the ps3 it just feels
like again it feels like
hubris once again you know pushed them
to make a console that is
advanced in cool ways but held back in
other ways that don't necessarily make
sense
when where you see where the rest of the
the industry is so i i don't know man i
don't know this if this is going to be
true or not but this is just
fields no i'm going to jump in because
that that's the reason why i brought
this to
the round table because you know we're
so close you know what is it october 4th
the system drops november 12th
so it's just like you know i've never
been in a situation where just like okay
what happens when i pick up a ps5
what's gonna work what's not gonna work
it's simple questions and it's not fan
point this is
literally we're asking what we're going
to pay for
and i think at this point there should
be a little vitriol there should be a
little
questioning it's okay to question if
something even if it's your favorite
console
it's okay to quit we do it with xbox hey
what's going on with this how come pc
games are
coming over here first like we have to
ask these tough questions
and that's the concern because look man
i like about my playstation i love these
experiences i love ghoster sashima and
all these games
i want to know if i i just platinum
gosushima i have all the
achievements and everything right i want
to know
on release date if i plug that in is my
data gonna be there or is my jin sakai
gonna have his bootleg outfit when he
just started like
i need to know these things like this is
pertinent information
you know what i'm saying so again you
know we're seeing at first i thought it
was just a single developer issue
you know okay then we hear the code
master thing then what miles spider-man
which one is it um
you know one of the versions i don't
know if it's the remastered or the
the miles morales part you know one
transfers and another does it so
i i'm just confused as to why
there is even an issue right because at
at some point
one would think it's in the cloud right
is is it the stage
on psn in the cloud so if i get another
playstation 4 it has my data
what is the technical reason as to why
they're having these issues that that's
the part
there's just no transparency there's no
clarity and i just feel
we should ask these questions it reminds
me of it reminds me of when i uh because
i'm a nintendo fanboy as well
um i brought home the wii u i remember
getting uh get my pre-order in
and realizing there's nobody else there
you know if you're a nintendo fan
you're excited you're excited new
consoles coming out like oh my gosh
let's do it so i
at the time she's my girlfriend my my my
now wife and i go pick up our wii u
we bring it home and i remember firing
up like yes new nintendo
and you fired up and like oh this isn't
very good like this experience is not
very good this is taking a very long
time to load up this ui
is awful this i'm not suggesting that
playstations ui is gonna be bad but
there's that moment when you fire it up
that it's either gonna wow you or it's
not
and i'll never forget my first day with
my wii u and i would just wonder
you know we're talking about all these
ideas it's hard to really wrap our minds
around like these
quality of life things it sounds great
on xbox but it's all these things that
people are saying
i could live without these things on
playstation until that's your reality
and then you plug it in
and you go i want my saves i kind of
expected these things all these things
to kind of happen
and i'm just wondering what that feeling
is gonna be like for people who drop
five six hundred dollars or wherever you
live in the world
it's a lot of money to have this and to
not know
until you know and you've spent the
money and then it's you're kind of sunk
at that point
it could be very disappointing for some
people and that that goes back to the
hubris thing it's like
really i mean i understand everybody's
been affected by covet i understand that
but you you're you you're you're banking
on me giving you five hundred dollars
right not you're not explaining to me
and we wouldn't get pre-orders you're
taking money yeah
you're taking money you're taking money
and you're not explaining
the entire console and that we would be
on xbox the same exact way
in our stadium
yeah absolutely it's like we would be on
them just the same way if they were
being quiet right now we are
we are literally less a little over five
weeks away
yeah well it doesn't matter they're sold
out anyways like that you can't get one
that's the problem and you're not going
to get one on the 12th
all right you can't get one and you're
not getting one on the 12th
this is a month out and you haven't seen
it you've seen it in a controlled
environment
in a room yo i am
absolutely so sorry to break this news
to you dudes
i thought it was going to be lit this
weekend i swear i
did so when i saw the information and
then cog hit me again
extra this morning to throw extra salt
in the womb um
i i threw up the video first of all i
knew
that they were going to be playing an
extended version of the astro land astro
boy thing
whatever that's built into the system
you know to get you used to the
controller
um and that's nice that little thing
that's cool all right
and um then they showed some godfall and
i heard that they played some
definitive uh devil may cry i didn't see
any of the gameplay of the devil may cry
but i did see the god uh god fall and i
i like uh little things that i saw in
the guard for as far as the red trade
[ __ ] and if the right tracks look good
and
and the stuff like that or what i
presume to be ray tracing because i am
not
a developer i i wait for digital foundry
to expose you dudes like they would
expose microsoft this whole
last generation right now the one that
we're in now and
and it was it was it was a good ride for
you dudes but the ride is over
right so i don't see no console coming
i have really gave up hope and believing
that it's actually going to launch
and i know you guys are so hell-bent on
saying king shut up they took my
pre-order
so what they got your money they don't
mean that you got the product
you didn't you didn't give them money
and they put a product in your hand
no that's called exchange of commerce
into products right that's called a
business exchange
no what you did was just do the first
form of the business exchange
now they must come through on their end
and i'm gonna tell you right
now it's really disconcerting
when i see all these influences we just
had jazz on he
has one there so that gives me a little
bit of faith
that they can deliver right if they got
enough to go around to give to youtubers
in the privacy of their own home
and they're not flying people out and
sequestering them inside rooms to put
them with
one and don't talk to the next dude
that's kind of shady stuff going on here
we don't see them out and about
it's controlled it's controllable it's
not control it's they don't have it and
like sovereign said
and you know what sovereign you are on
to something
if you don't have nothing good to say
don't say nothing at all you don't have
to
that's what i'm just about to say
because at the end of the day and again
we can only go by that's how i look in
life you only can judge a person
by their actions don't look at the
things they're saying you're gonna say
or not saying but
look at what they're doing and the thing
about it that is
to me very telling when you're not
willing to tell this much information
this close
but you're quick to put the playstation
information the the pre-orders you're
quick to put this stuff on right
tim i can only feel that you want to get
my money
quickly and then when i get it then i'm
going to discover things
but at that point it's too late because
i've already purchased i've already
pre-ordered
and again that's the part i have to be
honest king and normally you know i
usually go in on you i'm like oh you're
going too much
but you are onto something i don't like
the way it feels
it doesn't feel good that i can't get
basic questions answered does it feel
it's not honest not if it's not
that's what i'm saying we already we
just went through that with the
playstation 14.
we generated me and you got dragged over
the calls about the miles morales the
expansion the
the length of it and all this stuff and
people were like you how dare us
question and
again this is not fanboy stuff this is
just
you are a consumer you are about to
spend
five hundred dollars i mean you need
answers on what
you are purchasing that's all this is
it's it's like i said you know we had
a a huge demographic of playstation
fans it says look like this whole
generation you need to be on microsoft
you like
they're not giving you the games you
want you need to be on microsoft you
you need to demand better and it's like
i was saying last night in the party the
craziest part about this king
especially cognito and especially king
is
they in the matter of like six
hours they lied to you for a year and a
half told you generations
told you this told you that and in the
same breath as some of these you know
people that's been telling us to do this
telling us to do that they say
this isn't right sonia yo that pre-order
where i gotta go like
it's just right and another thing i
gotta say i don't want this excuses just
because the games
are great from the package that has
nothing to do with what you were talking
about yeah well they make great games so
i don't care if they need to
they can
the concept of games because as we've
seen in the past
studios change they don't have the
consistency
we how many people left naughty dog like
games aren't
guaranteed to be gold now sony has a
a very uh you know way better success
rate in making gold games
but it's not guaranteed next year is not
guaranteed to what you doing this year a
game can change from game to game from
studio to studio
they're not always going to do that and
there could always be variables that
change
and high leadership could change that
could change the whole company as king
was saying
management changes those are not the
same people everything is not always the
same so we can't assume
and it's okay it's a question you know
what threw up my red flag that really i
mean because before i was just joking
around playing around playing with the
tea leaves looking at it right
you know what really like set it all for
me
when they did the show and the bad
information was coming out
and then after the show the pre-orders
went live
yeah like that that rings to me like i'm
from the hood
okay i'm from the hood
that rings to me like yo throw your
money in the bag okay whatever you need
is already in your hair you'll go get
that
yeah and then you dip off then you look
in your bag and you're like
oh
what's up so when you don't have a
chance to
peruse the items and you know check and
see if you're joint authentic man
instead of getting balloons bellanciagas
you got balloon seagulls
like i'm sorry man i don't
trust you you ain't got that gucci you
got that good god you got that going to
go
you
downtown in chinatown right that had the
official
stuff right so we go into a side room
upstairs into the back
most grimiest place you will ever find
in your life
but they let you peruse the items
you can check and see the authenticity
you're looking you all right
now they have the scheissi joins up like
you buying or not you're buying
you're buying them not get get it and
then hurry up and pre-order
i don't listen i don't trust the
movements
and this is not sony let's let's keep it
a book this
is not sony and i know y'all want to say
but it's a pandemic
king it's a pandemic that's not an
excuse no
it's not an excuse you know what you let
let's before you do that let's go
here what this is is i'm convinced
that sony was loving that ride with the
ps4
and they took too long to take the ps5
into consideration and then they they
they panicked at the last minute they're
like oh we should have done this last
year
they probably made you know the wrong
decisions going forward to doing certain
things waiting for certain things
because you know obviously this is all
about a waiting game you see get the
price lower et cetera et cetera
and then now they're trying to do a year
and a half worth of work in six months
mm-hmm all we ask for is a little
transparency man let's get these super
chats so close so close to the uh
the launch is absolutely necessary okay
so hold on a second first off
let's welcome to the realm lord pick on
fusion remember to the round put them
questions
up thank you for the support much
appreciated hold on i'm gonna move back
to elemento pio
blowing into the dual sensor will both
cool down and up clock the ps5 cpu
salute the lord sean i remember him
shouting his podcast out at fan fest
last year
e3 has been a fan of the podcast
dude that is awesome man holy cow yeah
lucky to be a fan fast last year i can't
believe you remember that man what are
the chances we're in the same room
together that's great
dope good just asking don't forget be
careful all right
we got jonathan b with the five dollars
we're talking about what what xbox
might not have on the tone well i know
what sony won't have on the 12th
your saves enough memory a console
etc etc
[Laughter]
we have that's the 5 super chat if you
ain't into big girls you ain't gonna be
in the ps4 oh my god
this is the bbw of consoles
wow wow
today
i downloaded 360s fallout new vegas it
resumed my save file from the cloud from
10 years ago
wow how trash only is on the back compat
at that point
uh who did that for you yeah it's it's
just i mean
it's not to say they didn't work hard to
get it there but it's just there now
that's
just it they've been doing it a while
yeah exactly you just you got to put the
work in you know
right and we got sean sonny don't want
to go to the gym
oh
[Music]
xbox store in the coming soon right now
yakuza says series x
optimized okay let's hope let's hope
yeah but it doesn't say what
yeah that is true
shot his shout out
looks like he's trying to sneak out of
the room
that's why i put the gopro right there
to block him oh let me get j
doubles i had to drop a 20 spot because
king said willy nilly
i literally choked okay because i was
able to send this super chat
as for the crosshairs just ask the
playstation whisperer
mark cerny the playstation whisperer oh
my god
i didn't see much song oh my god just
caught that yeah
it makes you question all those devs
that said ps was easy to develop for it
this show is quick
it's cooler than king's new therapy
shoes
oh thank you man and they hurt like hell
then we have a yo greggy with the five
dollars in the chat yo
save game transfers on ps5 reminds me of
psn id name
changes in theory but difficult for them
to do good good trend yeah good
comparison yeah it's just
jean-marc louis with the two dollar
super chat i'm selling ps4 saves
insurance get at me i got it
you gonna go see you guys you got the
game hustle you got you got the hustle
okay all right then we got the wise old
gamer which
two thousand chapter ps4 saves are in
the bushes not the cloud
let me get let me get it again first of
all love to the
10 super chat gaming forte from the dps
podcast
first of all love to the ilp now slow-mo
dramatic pause
i know the frustrations of having a
superior co-host like myself
good things come to good people and our
lord has
blessed you with me love you slower
shout out to the dbs podcast co-host
being
messy and you know what forte
you might be on to something yeah yo
real talk man dps podcast gaming forte
slo-mo backslash follow them on twitter
follow their channels
great guys great chemistry great show
love those brothers man
salute to those guys absolutely then we
have lord
mariano pompa with the ten dollars chat
lord clark
sorry if you've answered this a while
back you talking about it was leadership
you need what he does when the chips are
down uh
where are you in his leadership thank
you good question good question yeah
shout out to mariano yeah i've had this
conversation with rand with king
look man i i was very hard on phil
coming into
this especially with the halo infinite
um situation when it got delayed
obviously the craig means it was really
low
so to me i don't judge people when
things are great i know he turned the
brand around i've already gave him that
credit
but for me i have to give him as king
said
that aurelius when it came down to the
bethesda deal
because short term he had to do two
things for me one
short term to put something to get the
fan base confidence at
launch to me i consider the ea access
acquisition people are sleeping on it
but i like that
he also he put that he made all the
third parties
drop their game on november 10th destiny
um assassin's creed all these games so
to combat the the halo infinite loss and
then the final thing where we give them
the as king would say the phil dominance
maximus aurelius
was bethesda i've been around gaming a
long time
excuse me not at that zenimax when
you make that level i'm giving respect
i'm bending the knee to you king
so when you when you make that level of
transformative
game-changing acquisition and i'm a
peter moore guy i'm a sega kid i ride
with peter moore
but even at peter moore's height he's
never
done a single move with that much impact
so
already i have to give his leadership a
tremendous a plus for turning it around
in a short period of time
cannot deny phil dominus maxim
but he's still got to win the generation
because i'm still holding on peter boy
as the 360 generation is the greatest
generation
the way playstation is doing it thank
you
it's looking nice for you right now you
gotta get out of here
playstation making all these mistakes
that i'm like come on like what's going
on
we might sweep them and fall wow
listen i want you to be very fearful
this is the fearful part because
and this is where i'm dead serious right
i'm dead serious
i'm deadly serious i don't care if they
survive or not
like i i don't care i sat there and i
watched neo geo
become a software developer i
watched nec go turbo graphic go for pc
engine to become a software developer
i've watched sega go from a hardware
developer to become a software developer
i saw a neogeo electronic arch memory
abandoned with them
yeah hardware software developer
i don't care if they survive i want
their games
flush them out phil dominus maximus
spencer
of aurelius spencer um
it's just still getting used to it i
want you to kill him off
i don't i don't want them around to
survive and we have parody about the
women and kids
i don't care about that and i know sony
fans is like how could you
that's black i want them finished i want
some alcohol
they can only
talk about these little pocket dudes
acting like they're competitive
they went
skinny jeans you know what i'm saying
i'm not worried about them dudes
listen rush them out get them out the
door get them out of the wall
sweep them and if you
so this is all about the first party
taking their first parties what could
make them a first party developer oh my
god
wow i want to rush them out the door
sweep them and then purchase them oh my
god
your new god of war
you know what everybody didn't have that
uh same energy when sega was getting
done up i'll figure it out i had to
switch it over right
and and i remember they killed your baby
they killed your baby
they murdered say that's what this is
this is my sega feel for that
and microsoft is the perfect foil to do
this too
i want it to happen so bad i want to see
the tear
i don't care about all that you know
because a lot of dude i'm so sick and
tired of
being a dude that got to turn off the
cheek i'm not turning out of the cheek
no more man it'll be nice
but you know they can't be coming to
monopoly let's see what happens if
they're
oh my god
[Laughter]
being over here condoning hammurabi's
law
he's got the 48 laws of
what power when they got total control
let's see
let's see whatever awfully happens all
right we have jay definitely
with the two dollar super chat you don't
have the jordan you got the hobbies
oh did we salute pecan uh fusion yes
okay we got him um and we have somebody
spin for the two dollars super chat oh
boy ps5 looking for
games
the playstation is upside down
backwards
[Laughter]
we have michael askew with the first has
anybody at the table had their ps5
pre-order canceled or delayed
no no yeah i'm good i got all four of
mine is still good
yeah what else you got and we have
regulator with the five dollars which
ps5 is so big it's going to be like
riding a scooter it's fun to see your
friends catch you riding in yo
wow with that you gotta put pause in
there stop that
show very two dozen chat yes it does it
says 60 frames per second
plus hdr 4k i'm looking at it right now
uh
is it highlighted though like are you
talking about yakuza
that's what you talk about what you
talking about shawn murray let us know
that link in the chat man because uh
lord gene wants to know because oh i got
to get ready let me get this one ray g4
the final super chat sony you want your
saves we have a console for you
it's called playstation wow
dom magic voice album oh my god then we
have
lord jonathan b with the five dollar
super chat king is like
sink the entire ship i don't care who's
left on it captain philip spencer
i'm the captain
oh
sup my lawyers no dog games on ps5 will
be good but not excited for it now
ps5 has to compete with series s because
the series x is on another level
yeah uh we got further confirmation and
shout out to dealer
who uh confirming what what he's been
talking about for a very long time that
there is a significant performance delta
between
the series x and the ps5 that is just
now
it's not not just now coming to light
but people are just acknowledging it now
teraflops then we have michael aka best
eyes finest with the 2
super chat king if sony dies they die if
they die
shout out to my brother boom stick xl
double barrel gaming you already know
five dollar super chat
let's go ilp my favorite show on sunday
thank you brother
anyone else disappointed with the
japanese youtube showing
it seemed very controlled uh king that's
that's that's our guy
i think the moment we found out you know
it was just japanese influencers we knew
that was gonna be controlled because you
only reach out to japanese influencers
when you want them to come to one
location
well the reason why he asked this
question is because i'm pretty sure that
he addressed this question on friday
with breakfast with boom
um that i'm usually on most of the time
i wasn't able to do it this week
so he's asking me a question because he
knew my answer was gonna be
hell yeah boom it was gonna be in a
controlled environment like we said
hell yeah boom it's gonna make sure that
they was in a room feeling isolated like
they had to answer the questions
and second when you do something of that
nature the person feels like
wow i'm chosen you have picked me
you've taken me here you've brought me
why am i alone
like
had more hands on the ps5
i can't watch it
better with the five dollar super chat
wait has sony showed you how to turn on
the ps5 yet oh wait do we have to blow
into the controller
the controller and turn it on the
message
we all caught up we're all good start i
think we got all rocks off with this
topic right definitely so
uh which one are we doing are we doing
mario kart next yeah we switch to mario
kart next year okay
so we got mario kart a home circuit got
another uh sort of video breaking down
exactly more of the game play how you're
going to set it up in your house
and king this is your topic and i was
very surprised to see you
you know you know how you do it when it
comes to switch stuff but
you you do always acknowledge when
nintendo's genius at times
and you kind of you were very excited
for this so talk about it
yo this is what's coming in hot why
this isn't giving a kick remember this
king topic y'all don't come for cops
this is not a cognitive topic this is
literally the greatest
invention to video games wow and i know
you're sitting there like ah shut up you
cap it
yeah okay right whoa this is what they
did
you know how normally you get a rc
control rc uh
uh race car and you gotta imagine your
own
you know track and sometimes you set up
your own obstacles
and you're like yeah you know you're
playing imagination
so what nintendo did was they removed
the remote controller and made it your
switch
right and they use the same lab or
cardboard
that we've been laughing at them about
but they have been keeping childhoods
alive across the world
and especially in this pandemic
you can set up an obstacle course
with your rc car that comes with a
capable camera
on it on your mario it's a whole mario
kart
and through your switch you control it
and it sets up the world you're playing
real life mario kart in your house
i would have died for this as a child
and i think first i know
this is going to outsell the playstation
5. this is going to outsold the xbox
series x and the series s
this is going to be the number one
seller
this holiday season if they can keep
this thing in stock
it will not stay on shelves i
i'm definitely buying this for my son
and if he doesn't play
with it you're going to see me right
here
playing with my switch in the basement
alone
ah you have mario i waited for this
damn near my whole life and somebody in
nintendo
just brought it to life let's get sean
capri on this because he's
he's got to i need i need to know what
he thinks about this
i was blown away man i wanted when i'm
i'm kind of with king on this i think
it's going to be a huge seller and it's
such a
like when you see it it's like well yeah
of course like that's what mario kart
should be in like a physical kind of
world i don't i don't know if i'm
getting it or not though because i'm
also kind of cheap with my kids we get
stuff like second hand
play with things for a couple seconds
like that my son's three uh named
lincoln so we could call him link you
know like true nintendo fans we got
ellie
as my daughter so you know playstation
fanboy as well um so i don't know if
it's going to be like this year but like
that is i could i just kind of want to
see where they go with it because the
concept i think looks really really good
um a little pricey a little pricey for
the for the three-year-old
but i'm i think it's amazing dude how
much is it i thought it was a hundred
bucks
i think it was like 100 i'm getting two
for a three-year-old i'm just saying
like
for what it is i think it's a great yeah
without no doubt we're gonna hear that
gene
well you know i i i'm sold on it king's
got me sold
i'm thinking like how stupid is this
thing and then i realized my nephews and
nieces are getting switches for
christmas this year it's like oh well
now i know what to get them
is it a curiosity factor in your heart
just to touch it just just to play it
once just to set up a track once just to
take yourself back to 13
15 year old gene just to set up a track
because
i know we all made our little obstacle
courses with our little gi joes or
whatever the hell we had our
movement or whatever and to actually
realize it in this vr world and
have a remote control car going through
the courses and then
having the the enemies attack you and
when it hits the car your car
stops or it spins out it's it's amazing
it looks like it's sold out everywhere
what no it's wrong
it was up anyway you could buy it oh
okay maybe i'm wrong but
i see you can't buy it so i'm just like
it's sold out
[Laughter]
lord lord addict how are you feeling
about it
you better say the right thing look man
mario kart 8 already exists if i wanted
to go and create something that's cool
but like i already got my mario kart 8
out of me
i don't really care about this but you
know king that's on you that's you good
man go for it
it's so sad that this 48 year old man
is so enthusiastic about going and
playing in the dirt with his little
child
and this young 20-something-year-old kid
he's just sitting there saying i don't
care go go knock yourself out
i mean glory day i was i was playing
mario kart when it came out and i
enjoyed it but i got it out of my system
that's fine maybe you didn't get it out
of your system continue playing
yeah okay you said you played mario kart
right
yeah did you ever envision what this
would look like if you was ever like
playing
in the real world like have it out like
you never
you never had that thought it did it
ever crossed your mind like
never nothing not really like i'm
i'm a very creative person when it comes
to stuff like that but you know i guess
could you imagine the tracks you can
make you're a creative person
i tried the mario um the mario maker
thing
and i ended up trading it in because i
didn't care anymore so like
i guess when it just comes to stuff like
that like it's it's a cool concept
but the creative part of me is dying
and the attic world part of me is is
increasing so
yeah so you know i'm gonna mail it to
what's crazy is you're the one that
doesn't like playing trials and doing
their job for you and they literally
letting you do their job for you
like we ain't even gonna make it king
here you here's the tools you make yo
you know what it is
i i purchased tiger tight tracks uh
night glow
racing we used to put together racing
tracks in my living room my cousin and i
and they the the wildest invention that
they made was when they was able to
suspend gravity
and go up walls so the race and
because before we was limited to just
the floor and then they
they made it that had a bend in the
track and it can go up walls and they
defy
gravity they made the magnets stronger
and we would purchase
new little racing cars and we will sit
there on predetermined tracks and race
each other
all day long now it has
released the shackles i mean it doesn't
go up the walls but
your living room is literally this is
toy story for
this real it like nintendo has a level
of creativity
and reckless abandon when it talk they
are
feverishly trying to keep creative
addict alive
like they they they're pumping juices to
them you said a hundred dollars i'm
buying one and sending it to attic and
i'm like please
send one to me i'll actually play it i
mean
you know king wants to get to try to
keep the creative addict alive being
creative
with no online infrastructure
it has no online infrastructure wait
till it's my turn
keep that at gamestop keep that again
i think that that's the biggest thing
that i just don't like about
microsoft not microsoft about uh
nintendo
i'm a huge fan of their games but it's
just like they don't want me playing
with my friends like
mario mario mario party
the sony type of environment where we're
only going to talk good things and show
good things about the console
when it comes to mario party like i love
that game i love the mini games like i
like
fall guys but it can't replace mario
party
and i'm very frustrated that a game like
fall guys
did something like on a massive scale
like that
before even nintendo did like nintendo
let someone else take they shine from
party games like
it just blows my mind and you know i was
a little bit behind on making the tracks
that's cool
but you know cognito over here telling
me there ain't no online like why would
i
what am i going to do like am i going to
make a am i going to make an
online track and then invite people
over to my house to play like like
am i if i could am i going to go over to
like
a subway or something like everyone just
play please look at my track
did you call time on yourself or was
that cog
it's it's it's not about you and your
friends across the world
like right now right here right now
i feel like have you guys seen this have
you guys seen his camera turn off
any of this because i feel like he is he
is he this isn't the same king
this isn't the king during the xbox
tomorrow this is
king's topic oh
when you realize what it is it's my my i
was like when i realized what it is
that's what i'm like i don't want it
like but when i saw it i said no mario
kart well i said that look real as hell
i said resolution i said it's the new
switch
hidden in the streets man i saw what
they
was doing and i yelled from the living
room babe
come here and i restarted the video and
i said that look real as hell right she
was like yeah that looked like a
living room they doing real good
except let me look up this trailer
what's this thing
see i mean how many cats and dogs are
you getting actually
live home circuit yeah i said look uh
actually yeah let's go to [ __ ] let's go
okay mario kart
live yeah mario kart live home circuit
all right i i will do my research and
i'll be
i'll be right back be right back so look
here's the thing you know
one thing about nintendo is they
definitely think outside the box right
they always do something that we say
you know wow like who even thought about
that right
and on straight face value what this
thing is doing is definitely unique
you're doing the race track thing
it's like a you know augmented reality
kind of thing and and it's physical with
the toys
i get it but then when you start peeling
the layers
of how you do this and it's like okay so
now i gotta pay a hundred dollars for
this thing
you know in order for two people to play
they have to have their own copy their
own switch right
and this thing then we gonna physically
set up the thing and i'm like okay
i could listen this is not for me
let's just put this out there but into
king's defense i know this is going to
sound
like this is one of those things that i
look at nintendo like
why like who why and who is this for
but like labo proving cog wrong
once again like it sells i know that
this thing seems like the most craziest
thing to me like no one's gonna want it
but i know it's gonna sell it was just
funny to me when it came out
you know i'm saying so at the end of the
day you know i think the
the online infrastructure would have
been nice but i do see the little ar
stuff it's just one of those it's
nintendo being nintendo
with ingenuity but for me i'm just like
i don't know
any other major manufacturer that can
get away with this
it's for kids it's it's a whole like rc
car thing and
you know even the more i think about it
like like lincoln is playing games now
he's playing mario 3d world we give him
the wii u it's perfect for him
but he does the zombie thing talking
about attic like he does the like when
he's playing
he is locked in and you're like lincoln
lincoln and you're like shaking him
like like snap out of it this snaps him
out of it i kind of like that it's like
let's
play with something that's mario that is
nintendo but it's not like stare at a
screen
you know for hours on end all right so
yeah
this is straight in the bushes this is
this is straight in the bush why is he
straight in the bushes
i at first i thought you guys were
talking about like you know a genuine
you make a a track you get a play you
could upload it kind of like mario maker
yeah but this is some gimmick stuff
ain't nobody gonna do
like th this is like one of those things
they're saying
put play in your house like
no no i try to go home to play games on
a screen like i try
i try to have a race in my house like
you you won't purchase a switch for zach
and you and zach can get your tracks on
in the ground
get my tracks off y'all not gonna sit
indian-style on the floor yeah
indian stuff you know what i'm just too
you know
i i'd rather play tetris the oldest
child
in the world i'd rather play tetris
that whatever this is i don't know and
you know i went to amazon
and i just saw that they have a mario
edition
now what that tells me right there the
collector and me with all the
amiibos wow they just told me
they're gonna have a yoshi edition
they're gonna have a luigi edition oh my
god they're gonna have
a peach edition it's going to sell like
hot cakes it's going to
make brewery hold on let me let me
interrupt game unfortunately chat he
says i love podcasts i have
shout out to him get out the game i have
54 copies of that game pre-ordered at my
store
he said many people buying two copies
again i look at i'm like how and that's
why i don't even i don't even doubt
nintendo anymore
you know what i'm saying like clearly
they're good
like you know i'm just like wow this
it's gonna sell there's gonna be even
even if it doesn't work well like
i appreciate their ingenuity nintendo
are toy makers bottom line
at the end of the day they're they're
the mad toy makers
and i appreciate it and they always do
things to to speak to the different
sections of their of their user base
whether it's adults or whatever they're
always going to take care of the kids
but what
what gets me is like yo dude you still
have an issue with like joy-con drift
um i can tell you right now i'm playing
hades hades and
and and zagreus be running back and
forth by himself sometimes
because he just does his own thing um so
yeah
joy-con drift is real imagine you
driving this car around and your joy-con
is doing whatever it feels like doing it
and it's like but again
they know how to make money hand over
fists if that's what they know
this is what they know how to do they
may not know internet they may not know
a lot of things
they know internet money
they may not know internet
[Laughter]
out of control this topic was great i
gotta give king credit
oh this is this is hilarious there is a
luigi edition
yes
talking about like man it's is
as a child i would have do you want to
as a child
our childhood would have went crazy you
see my basement as a reflection
letting go we coming from the hot tracks
the rc cars we come from that era so our
generation is kids would have loved to
have something like this
those cars were 25 cents each yeah yeah
absolutely it's just
i'm surprised that they're able to do
this stuff with this generation of kids
and
you know that not really playing in the
house no more like
these adults buying this yeah these
iterations are online and
youtube and twitch so it's just
surprising to me that they still are
able to resonate no matter what they do
i agree with kingdom i think it is the
adults buying it to try to force their
children away from you
no no no no listen listen i showed my
son it right yeah
he's like we're right upstairs to go
play doom eternal
he went right upstairs to play doom and
turn he's like yeah whatever old man
and i don't care like i
i'm not gonna buy it for him anyway so
this is this is your purchase i spread
i'm gonna buy it for him but i also told
you i'm gonna be downstairs in the
basement playing about
yeah so when i'm gonna put up a
video he's gonna be indian style on this
idiot
there's gonna be indian style on that
floor behind him
going in a circle around mario over and
over again
you're gonna set the tracks up around
barriers i want to see when they're
when the car refuses to stay on the
track
look man it's like i said i don't i
don't question
so i don't question nintendo anymore
they they they so they fans
plast no they sewed their fans cardboard
they sold their fans cardboard
nintendo can do anything at this point
yeah
i'm not come out you ain't gonna front
like
when we is he really about to capture
he's really about his life
to play uh play new york uh play craft i
know we wanna be
to be more positive on nintendo from
time to time but man he's taking this to
the heart
i remember going to play craft new york
and
when they had that label section
remember cod yes yes
and the dude was playing the piano on
the joint
and i just looked at him and he just
blew me the hell away
he blew me away like like he had
one of those real like times
remember this moment because you're not
going to see a lot of this is rare from
cake
soak this up before we move on
[Music]
i usually agree with you on most things
especially xbox related but this ain't
it fam
oh no let's transition to the super chat
cause
we have a couple of consenting opinions
on that
we have j.w with the five dollar super
chat jim ryan
a2 phil dominance maximus aurelius
phil proceeds to engage in multiple
shanks uh
we got a little julius caesar and brutus
going on there
and then we have the wise old gamer with
the five dollar super chat king
you seem wary the ps5 do you have issues
handling extra thick girls
wow let me help you first you take the
blue pill and then the ball
he won't stop that's okay
wow you know what in the bowl cream
cream shout out to jess then we have
cedric h
the ten dollar super chat ps you want
those saves check out our only fans for
that premium content
squirrely dead canadian fighter last
time i had to blow into something to
make it work was the nes
step
sup wanted to show some support this
sunday keep up the good work
p.s king king have knees sent to saab
since there's no slide card reader on
the ps5 thank you
thank you i don't know about that
low-key proof i have videos
like i said like i said i never agreed
to any stipulation
look at song getting out of it
like a million stipulations that i never
agreed to
hold up get real quick real quick
everybody in the
chat if you think king got saul's knees
put a 1. got king's knees
put a 2. if y'all don't put it in color
it don't count
oh my god
buying the mario kart home circuit for
his almost four years old but he said
low key
i'm playing it myself shout out to hide
lords of david dot that the building
i told sovereign this is about the knees
with sovereign losing them right
wow sony just confirmed if your breath
stinks the controller will lock itself
and step down wow
99.99 of the time i'm in your corner but
right now is where the point zero one
percent crazy
throw yourself into the bushes throw
yourself in the bushes
see thank you you was coming for me
thinking it was my topic
yo it could be in color but it still
don't count thank you though i
appreciate it
[Laughter]
what bad people who what's the number
one represent that they come up with a
song
some of these as well oh they say it's
everybody saying one one one
that's not no i didn't think about any
of that yo tell me how it told me how
my man scrub nerves put in color one
color one squirrely dab what soft stitch
one spinny spit everyone wants your
knees off
yeah because i i'm not i haven't had to
have to you know
bend the knee for anything so i have to
eat this i'm not eating this
stop refusing to the egg are we all
caught up i did not stipulate any of
this yes we're caught up thank you
thank you for your donations all of you
oh my god
last topic this would be good this is my
topic
gentlemen we are five weeks away from
the conclusion of the eighth generation
of consoles
night generation is upon us and the
eighth generation
let's just say there's been a lot to
talk about and as the next couple of
weeks go on we'll probably you know
have a little retrospective and talk
about all the things that happen this
generation
but today i just want to talk about what
are your guys
10 best games of the generation
is a lot man i feel like we should i
feel like we should just dedicate a
whole show to this at this point
what i suggest we do what i suggest we
do
per person yeah we we just we just go
over like
your favorite game
and at the end of the year we do a whole
show dedicated like the top tip
like a whole show dedicated to the top
10. all right so let's go
let's go through five number five and
just talk about it really quickly
um uh king lord king david with the five
dollars
attack one damn it
they're hilarious guy boston you better
watch what you say bro
who's that og bet was no free back
compat at all bet is already lost with
ps4 the ps5 free upgrade
thank you blood is sticking there look
at kyle defended his brother
the bet was if i put in any disc and it
don't work back up
once again that was the stipulation that
i said no to
okay okay okay what we'll do is we will
pin this
to spin the knee and we'll have someone
go back and uh
and look up the speculations to what
happened it won't be attic but it'll be
someone
uh and we'll figure out what happened i
have i have um kaibatsu on that don't
worry about that oh he got the video
proof
because every time i asked him to show
me where i said that he refuses
so i know what it is but if you're right
then why not show me
right so listen man
i got one thing to say to you i got one
thing to say
i got one thing to say to you saul he
said what he said
[Laughter]
let's let's go let's go come on let's
get to this topic let's go with our
guests first let's go with lord it's on
capri first
okay i just need to say that i wasn't
prepared for this at all
no no no no all good all good you can
always change when you come just do
three
it don't take forever to go back and
forth is easy part is easy we don't have
to go
i don't know i don't even have two to be
we don't have to you've got to come on
stop
just listen i think honestly the one
that i spent the most time with it like
completely changed my opinion on like
the overall franchise which is one
that's been along for
a long time was assassin's creed odyssey
i think might be my favorite game this
entire gen
that thing i probably put 120 hours into
which is very much not like me there's a
lot of other games pulling up my
attention
um but like i went with cassandra across
all of greece i did all the things i met
testicles
and his whole adventure
which i put that knee bending as a
patreon tier i
got you yo what though you know what's
funny i'm in charge of patreon
[Laughter]
the iron bank is savage
i'm sorry he just scared me because
there's something inside that that
that thing that i'm saying i thought he
did something else yeah we thought
something about we thought well yeah
well he's been known to do all the lords
sorry
look at look look he kicked sugar a
little bit there
no i was about to just leave
there's only one man that puts fear in
the iron lawrence
and that is will be hood i was just
about to just
leave so you know what's funny before we
found out people like will be existed
i'm so glad i ain't putting nothing
ridiculous on that picture oh man i'm
so glad i didn't put nothing ridiculous
he'll make you do it then look in the
eyes that i did that to you
and he told me actively yes
so the rest of your list all right i'll
keep going um forza horizon 3
was a game that i got up at five in the
morning to play before work i wanted to
put hours into that game the entire time
um and then on sony land bloodborne i
know there's
some people are kind of like this is the
game of the generation and my friend mr
bad bet game of the generation he's
keeping track of the days since
that game came out that was the one that
introduced me i remember i was playing
that game
just kind of brian latonne from ign he
had his old experience or just something
clicked
i had the very similar experience not
understanding it going playing for hours
and then just some and then i got it and
i just understood that it was like
such a rewarding experience for me i
think it looks great i think it plays
great
um rocket league is something that
people kind of overlook to because now
it's like free to play
and i played a bunch of like a bunch of
that game
i'm trying trouble kind of like landing
on the fifth one man like i know a lot
of people are throwing like breath of
the wild out there but i don't know if
that's like is that this generation
because we're talking about we talk
about
this this generation is ending and
switch is kind of it's kind of going on
man
yeah i don't know i like i'll throw in
like a i'll throw in a shout out to
dragon age inquisition
i love my bioware games and i really
like that game of 2014.
that was a good one absolutely lord jean
uh i am going to say breath of the wild
that's definitely one of my favorite
games of all time um yakuza zero
uh kind of got things started with me in
yakuza uh the witcher 3
one of the greatest games ever made and
um a game called minute that's on every
platform i think it's on game pass right
now
mi nit it's a zelda light game it's one
of my favorite games ever made
made by a small team three or four
people absolutely fantastic you die
every 60 seconds it's like a really cool
concept
and then i'd say spider-man in no order
um
they did a beautiful recreation of
manhattan and i like had to put down the
controller and cry one time i saw my
office like in the game
the recreation of grand central stations
oh man pretty unbelievable
and the story and the villains reminded
me of the cartoon from the 90s and that
was you know everything i wanted out of
that game
so i can get this over with yes please
uh i would have to say persona 5 even
though i still haven't beat that game i
know it i'd have to say final fantasy 7
remake
did you say x-com uh
the chosen what about me let's go yeah
that's
three um i can't can't give it to zelda
zelda i think it's a good good game but
it's not it's not a good zelda game
i think that's i can't give it to
uh to odyssey i want to give i'm going
to give it to god of war i'm going to
give it to god
first of all that's strong and
bloodborne yeah no no i'm going to take
that back chakra shadow dies twice i
think that's slightly so
you got second row over bloodborne yeah
i think that's slightly better than
bloodborne
just because the audio design i think
the audio design and checker when you're
like blocking those moves and
you hear that clean click clean like it
feels like a legit
like like a battle like bloodborne it
just felt like i'm hitting a big
object that i i just see health coming
down like the monsters and bloodborne
the settings
he said you you you sweating sony too
much threatening sony too much who's
going on he used
to use other words i can't you know who
said that
they don't nintendo always be coming for
you oh no squirrely
what did i say that that upsets you what
did i say that obsession
too many saudi games too many sony games
well i'm sorry sony making the gold
like they're making the go it's not my
fault it's not you gonna have to talk to
microsoft nintendo
maybe if they update game they'd be more
of those games on that list but it's not
my fault
oh yeah let's go with you
um you know i'm biased so we gotta have
i know you're gonna say oh it's death
yeah it destiny too forsaken is the
greatest one of the greatest expansions
they've ever made
shout out to the dreamer city
they're timing me all the time shout out
to the last wish raid i thought that
was amazing and the fact that when you
beat the main campaign
it transformed into another game the
dreaming city is one of the most
beautiful
tolkien like experiences ever so that um
i forgot this game on my list yesterday
when they were doing that top four stuff
inside inside about it
is one of my games of the generation yes
yes as a kid who came from games like
another world and and stuff like that
where it's environmental storytelling
and you don't know what's going on
and the game has two of the one of the
best extra endings that make you
interpret it a whole different way
so inside is one of my joints um got a
shout out attic
xcom 2 baby the best turn base ever
what i've chosen it just on another
level
on another level it was neither between
that or destiny
and i've enjoyed destiny probably more
than xcom
but when i was playing x-com i was
playing x-ray and it was difficult
the story was great the character
development was great and it's the best
turn-based game there's no there's
nothing better
than getting getting destroyed at the
beginning
and then when you start turning the war
around it's like oh
where's those chosen now
right like because it really does not
like you have to survive
so anyway enough of that another game i
forgot on my top four
titanfall 2.
first of all respawn are the gods those
those are my guys
type 41 was amazing we only just
complained about the narrative
and boy did they do a narrative but bt
and the relationship with your titan
also the online was amazing
last time standing the variations of the
different type of
titans i mean titanfall i cannot wait
for the third one that's why i get mad
when i see apex legends but
type one two that's up there and the
last one of course i gotta say my man
guru's in here
yeah breath of the wild man made me
believe in nintendo
i just i couldn't give it to him man
this is my
time this is my list so like i would say
the reason why is as a sega kid i
never really was a nintendo guy like
that you know and
after the wii u king knows i i laughed i
stopped buying nintendo consoles
since um damn since the gamecube yeah i
i was like i'm not buying a wii that's a
gimmick i'm not buying a wii u don't
like it
i refuse king saw when i took my stance
against nintendo because it was no third
party
and i didn't like the games when i saw
breath of the wild
that was a console experience then on
the go
it was the it was just amazing the open
world nation do anything go anywhere
climb anywhere no restrictions you could
even go to the end of the game at the
start of the game if you wanted to
like the game truly was transformative
it it made me believe in nintendo
it made me become a fanboy of nintendo
like
that singular game like i'd never forget
it man and salute the king
for putting me on to amiibos i never
forgot i bought that wolf amiibo
for that game so i had that little wolf
around me doing the difficult parts in
the beginning
right so salute to amiibos and nintendo
getting all my money
for the breath of the wild i got to give
it up no doubt that
lord king
first game rise son of rome
wow um because that made
me he's gonna put one playstation
to give them a bone it made me go
absolutely
ate crap to get it like
the game still looks phenomenal to this
day i don't even understand
what level of technology they was
working with and why it wasn't purchased
to this day i don't i don't get it it
doesn't make any sense
um destiny
destiny destiny as a as a whole
destiny as a whole because it has
consumed my gaming life like
actually i it's not a week that don't go
by that i don't put in at least 40 hours
and then get on that list
shut up shut up
so um third
game let's go third game um
spider-man yeah that one that makes you
beat attic i think addie bend the knee
it wasn't even about at it it was about
when sony showed the trailer i said hell
no there's no possible way they can ever
achieve anything like that
and you know that scene when he's
jumping through the
the store that they never achieved that
scene but
the aspects of the game that they did
achieve
it was outrageous it was spider-man it
was the best spider-man that we've ever
received in the game form
so yeah spider-man
stands out that's that's my third um
okay
two more two more my fourth
is the last of us two two i knew you was
good yeah yes
that's your joke i'm talking about
so quaking emotion
me crying in front of the television
and not wanting to choose something
like me dreading the outcome
of a video game
hands down that the best developer
in anyone's stable and i can understand
why people feel
that you got that bullet in your chain
but you gotta
um and
the fifth game
it's purely on how it makes me feel
i was so done with resident evil
resonant evil even the remakes i was
done
with the whole the whole thought process
of it
and i really had a time to sit there and
think about
this game to be my number five
resident evil 7
creeps me out in a level
that it's it's i know for some it may
they may say nah king i like this
okay that's that's good for you this
joint is really plausible right right
it goes back to old horror films
like texas chainsaw massacre
and the blair witch it it takes you to
these
really visceral so like the glob
creatures wouldn't bother you much
you said what like the the creatures
like how they like
black glue like that that that
that's it i thought it was a good it was
a good game though there's no denying
that it was a good game
well that's the resonant evil stuff to
it but
to give it that extra layer of
plausibility
with the the maniac stuff that's
happening to it
and to add a resident evil flavor the
way to reinvent
uh uh uh ip i think they did it
perfectly
and i'm really anticipating resident
evil 8 if this is direction that they
they choose to be in
and i think it seems like that so i'm
trying i'm forcing myself to finish this
game
because the level of horror and fear i
have
sliding through a wall knowing that i
have to get to this i was in a tunnel
right
this is and i don't mean to go on on
this tangent but scared the hell out of
me
i'm getting away from this lady she's
chasing me there's no weapons that you
have
you're just trying to escape and i'm
in this crawl space looking for a way
out
and the lights is turning off around me
and i thought my console messed up just
happened here
and then the lady pops out of the dark
with them
in my face and said now
i brought my controller and screamed you
know what the
you know one of the craziest parts about
the game
is is when she you can get your head cut
off and they
sew it back on like i remember when i
played that game that she cut my hand
off and i picked it up i'm like that's
mine
[Laughter]
you gotta put that in vr with the lights
off it's amazing
i don't get that type of you know in my
life if we talk about vr
resident evil the first thing i am doing
with my life is screaming time
i purchased that vr that was the best vr
game period
for them right when i put my head
in inside the vr's face and i looked
around i said oh hell no
then i put it back in and i looked
around i'm playing the game
and my girl touched my hand while i was
playing
the thing is man is last when it comes
to playing like
i i got creeped out playing that like
without vr like
i'm too white to play that with my blood
pressure like i i would end up having a
heart attack like yeah
this is true it's absolutely true the
most horrifying game
for me this generation i'm pretty sure
people have other stuff
i haven't tried it but this this is it
that's my 5.
let me finish out here yeah let's get it
man ah so my number five
and i have to concur with uh with cog on
this
inside and feel free the chad definitely
put your top five in the chat
you put your top five in the chat inside
the the jump that play dead made from
limbo to inside
absolutely bonkers to me that game
people wonder like
it's a small game and you wonder why
that game took six years to make
it's because every aspect of that game
every little piece of that game was
created specifically to do
one thing there aren't any reused assets
it's it's it's really like it almost
feels like a like a very story based
game
where frame to frame screen to screen
it's telling you a story yes so they had
to account for you being able to do
different things in those scenarios
while still doing exactly what they
wanted you to do
and not affecting the pacing of the
story and
and the pacing of of when things
happened to you
that game is bonkers bro inside it's
because this is so amazing
i show that to non-gamers and they get
into that game and they
love it and they're like what is this i
just picked it up on this so i picked it
up on a mobile or whatever
and and the ending is one of those
things that just makes you say what
mind-blown yeah definitely mind-blown uh
yeah
one of the top games of the generation
uh number four for me is god of war
oh yeah first god of war there you go
god of war
they for me they took a character that i
was sort of done with i was sort of done
with the you know the
angry cradles but kind of angry for the
sake of being angry
um and i i was done with that combat too
i know king
you know doesn't doesn't agree but i was
sort of done with that combat so what
they did with this game
um in terms of making him a character
that i felt about like an adult type
character that's actually going
if you think about the stuff that kratos
did in his life
it's logical that he would feel this way
right um
and i just think it was a beautifully
made game i loved the combat
yes there was a lot of repetition in in
the uh in the enemies and i i hope in
the next one they sort of
rectify that but beyond that i i love
everything about that game that's one of
the few platinums i do have
on on on our playstation and it's a
single camera the whole time
yeah like the whole journey is like
there's no cuts it's that's really
remarkable
a single shot camera is something that
you don't notice unless they tell you
about it and then
do know about it you can't unsee it and
it's like
like really like every single day never
they never break away from the action
um and i think it gives it an intimacy
that a lot of games don't have
for that reason um so that's not number
four number three
goes to the witcher 3
it's the first time i've seen an open
world rpg
with that level of detail and attention
to
side quests that makes the world feel
alive in a way that
other rpgs don't necessarily do when you
when you go into like a fallout the side
stories are great
but once the side story is done it isn't
always the case where it kind of doubles
back onto the main story in a way that's
meaningful
the witcher did that across its entire
campaign
um and it's just it it that's such a
difficult thing to do that that's why
i'm so excited for cyberpunk
because if cyberpunk is as dense or even
denser than witcher 3
and those same connections exist that's
going to be a game for the ages just
because of that interconnectivity and
and sort of
giving the world life that you don't see
normally in rpgs
right so that's number three yeah it's
it's
it's a bonkers game and the amount the
just the amount of
of content is crazy in it of itself i
started it probably like three times
like i played the first like maybe five
ten hours like three times i haven't i
haven't
quite gotten through it the one thing
that like throwback to like dragon age
was i loved like that my universe
carried through
yeah i played the earlier games like
that was a big deal for me i would love
to see more and more developers and
and um cd projekt red do that a little
bit more like bring it bring your your
choices and your decisions forward in
games
yeah absolutely amazing game amazing
game
um number two for me is red dead
redemption 2.
i knew it was coming i was like where
does it go where is it
it's number two for me that is a game i
know you guys don't agree
but it is a game that you you can live
in like you literally exist in that game
um art forget about arthur morgan as a
character and he's an amazing character
but the things you the things that they
gamify in that game
appeal to me in a way that allows me to
sort of lose myself in that world
what game are we talking about yeah you
shut them yeah here we go
red dead redemption 2 time you eat horse
simulator
no i don't i'm not like you that went
into that game thinking i'm playing
destiny or something oh they're shooting
to give it to rockstar like rockstar
with every single game and i know
i know gta 6 is going to outdo it i know
this
is what they do they nobody can one-up
rockstar except themselves
and again this game it just lets you
inhabit it the story is fantastic
oh my god anyway let me move on to my
number one because
i was just thinking about the gameplay
too long like that he's
gonna love this one too uh my number one
breath of the wild
man like like i said when i when we
first talked about the game gonna throw
this fraud alert why are you talking
i forgot he in control it may not be
listen breath of the wild may not
may not have everything that that a
classic zelda gamer wants
but i think they rectify that in breath
of the wild too but
what it did and i talked about this when
we first talked about the game
it just doesn't have the literally
foundation of zelda but okay continue
jesus christ
don't you love that you don't have
access to this
hey i hate to continue
listen when i first played the original
legend of zelda when you're a small kid
and you have imagination that apparently
doesn't have anymore
you you imagine these worlds in a way
vividly in a way that you know at that
point in time
graphics can't show you right and i felt
the same way like when i painted
adventure on the atari 2600 like
i imagined the world that wasn't in
front of me breath of the wild was the
first time that my imagination
met with reality and when when link woke
up and he walked out onto that cliff
in the entire world in front of you
and the entire world was literally at
your feet and you could do what you
wanted to do
what i i was blown away i never had a
game done that for me and the fact that
it
you know i have to say this the fact
that it's on hardware like the switch
doing that sort of stuff
bro it kind of made me love it even more
but i can't believe they're doing this
on this
all the different systems i got to
interrupt so all the difference is the
cooking
the the so if you're positive you can
earn
so the portal stuff when you're moving
the box and you're manipulating the
world
there's so many different containers and
just and and
and the game changer to me climbing
everything
yes the fact that link can climb
everywhere
every single thing and when you
literally you look out over
my way straight out of that game
you love it don't fry you boys
of the wild drop and you could almost
see a 10 is uh how emotional he got
it i probably watched that troll like 10
50.
i love breath of the wild i just think
as far as a zelda game it's one of the
worst zelda games
second generation though but do you
think it's one of the worst
zelda games or is different it's not
what
it just doesn't have the foundation of
zelda that i enjoy and the temples
to me is the foundation of the game like
that is literally what zelda was built
on was temples
right and it was in the of a generation
this is a new generation
that's it for you and your job i think
they're going to bend them
as redemption
yeah that is that game is transformative
in a way um
that i just it blew me away so that you
know what there will be a funny
everybody saying time
time to talk they agree with they agree
with the addict
i mean it's okay to be wrong you can be
wrong
all right no doubt so let's get these
last super attacks before we head out
in a long time all right let me see
you could ride a horse in breath of the
wild by the way
yeah which nobody does uh let me see uh
we have
okay no we have the hot we have
squirrely damn with the redacted
first thought i love you i'm not gonna
read it i
love you but i'm not gonna read this
question
all right so what squirrely put in there
he said uh
four four hundred dollar uh t next tears
uh king davids and i i redacted it i was
trying to be funny and redacted and try
to put it back but i couldn't put it
because he wants to bend it well you got
to explain yourself you want us to have
a bending moment
here i run patreon so that's that's oh
my god
will we we can put a bending to need to
i don't have to talk
i don't know i don't know what you're
talking about
they want us to physically bend the knee
on camera we could put it too for that
time
time let's go let's go let's go all
right we have stitch with the 2 super
chat no hellblade from any of you
interesting hellblade is fantastic
um again we're doing top five
well we're doing our list yeah we're
doing top five
um hellblade is fantastic um it didn't
make my top 10.
it's transformative i am going to work
with
the rest of lords i think we are going
to have like a generation podcast
since the end of the generation maybe
sometime in december we'll have like a
generation podcast where it will just be
our favorite games this generation oh
yeah
yeah so then we have sin vendetta with
the five dollar super chat
top five this generation number one
bloodborne number two
and sanctuary okay like certain type of
game game
is very good uh three god of war four
dark souls
three five resident evils
someone else loves that resident evil 7
all right so that is it for us ladies
and gentlemen
thank you for joining us for this
marathon episode of the island
i don't even know it was that long i was
having so much fun yeah absolutely so
let's go with lord sean capri man thank
you for joining us and
and tell everybody where they can find
you thanks for having me guys this was
awesome holy cow anytime um i got to get
you guys on my shows as well you can
find me
on twitter at sean capri at sean like
connery capri like the pants
and i feel like all the people you're so
stupid
if you like the xbox chat then i i
record a podcast from my car
it's called the xbox drive uh you can
check that out every thur yeah
every thursday on spotify and everywhere
else um
i do a show called with gamercast where
i sit one on one i have
sweet hangs with the stranger from the
internet lord cognito is on there we've
got to get king got to get you guys on i
think that would be
absolutely amazing he really does a
fantastic job with that show
yeah it's just a just get to know one
another and kind of get to your back
story what you're into like you
kind of just have really remarkable
stories from a lot of people like how
they grew up and
just things are important to them so
love doing that show and uh a cup of joe
nintendo with uh nintendo
the girl at the time again we're gonna
get you back brother we gotta get you
back in the room definitely
i also want to say quickly a couple
people were throwing ori in the chat i'm
embarrassed i should have mentioned orie
it would be on my top ten or even though
the west would be on my top ten
definitely it might get there because
i'm playing right now so it might make
mine mm-hmm i mean i think king
described so many great games just to
check that
hard dead cells i didn't get it well
we'll get into that man like i'm really
serious we're going to have that vodka
dead cells dead cells in hades aren't my
top 10. so that's what's up
i almost said among us i really did i
came that
close but i haven't played it enough to
justify
it being over like x-com or anything
like that
all right uh no doubt so now we have uh
lognet's own scribe of the month or gene
good morning congratulations on that on
on the scribe of the month
yeah whatever they can find you man
thanks guys um
37 gene 37 on twitter if you go to
lognet i'm right on the front page now
okay i guess
that's the most um if i get a bunch of
followers from this or you know either
way
i've got about 15 20 steam codes all i'm
going to tweet out uh during the week
um maybe tomorrow i'm not sure and um
thanks for having me on guys absolutely
keep up the fantastic work brother i
love you as a part of this team
absolutely man you're such a big part of
that team absolutely so happy
so happy and then we have hayton alley
addict
see you're just mad soft i didn't let
you in attic world i know you've been
wanting in
i just didn't let you in because i don't
let people that like horse simulators
in the attic okay the mayor shuts that
down you don't
cross that border the governor the
president
everything man i am i am the absolute
that's all you need to know
i'm not any form of government i am the
absolutes
but you can find me on twitter at lord
addict iop
uh you can find me on youtube at gaming
addict i have been very absent on
youtube the past week i'm in the middle
of a move
but that will be rectified tomorrow so
everything should be good there should
get that content up
i had currently have a bet going on with
gaming4town who can i make the most
content in the month of november i don't
know the month of october
which i will be claiming that at the end
of the month uh and you can also
find me uh here every week at the iron
lords podcast
so i definitely will be here next week
now i do have an announcement
uh we do have room for another emo so uh
you know the members and the patreons
i'll be dropping another poll giving you
guys the option
to pick the next emote that
is in that chat so if you guys aren't
members or if you're not
uh youtube uh members or if you're not
patreons definitely go there
go to those individuals and if you're if
you're double dipping you get two votes
sorry about that but it's just how it is
i definitely appreciate everyone that's
been here appreciate all the guests from
coming on appreciate jazz from coming on
and giving some insight on the series x
and we'll see you next week
no doubt when we said you're going to
lose a bit forte does 30 podcasts a week
no those don't count no streams don't
count
oh it's actually creative content okay
create a content fair enough
no doubt lord king where the fine people
find you
well you can find me on twitter
acting crazy like you like addict i love
the twitter
um first i wanna shout out to sean
you're definitely sean have me on
whenever you're ready i don't care shoot
me at the dm
and i'm definitely gonna be there with a
collection like yours hell to the yes
let's do it time to talk about it and
thanks to your your motivation too you
and cog too just keeping everybody
moving and stuff i love watching your
guys's
motivation all your all the things you
guys are throwing up here on twitter
it's amazing
big time yeah
every time i see that i hate them a
little more because i'm just like man i
really need to get out and start like
walking or do something
literally i literally tried to just warm
up the other day i threw out my back i
haven't been able to move all
i go from the weekend to the upstairs to
this podcast i sit in my gaming chair
and i'm like
man that's some good exercise you're
ridiculous
i do that to fight depression and stuff
like that i love it i love it
because uh you know you just got to feel
better about yourself with things and if
you don't like something go change it
that's how you know
yeah right oh but uh shout out to gene i
mean gene is one of my favorite new
people that i've met
and i mean be honest with you it was
seeing you
it packs yes it's look i think
if you don't know from me from now i
take the little things so like
when i'm really sick i'm really serious
about that mario kart thing right and i
really feel the
thing about it but i take the little
things because people take a lot of
things in this life for granted
but when you were talking to developers
and you were moving and you were shaking
you to see you in your element i said
this is beautiful
right and and and this man came
and put his trust in us fashion
and he's here with us in fact you know
that that that
that humbled me so much and you worked
so hard because as we were sitting
inside that media room everybody heads
down and everybody's working
and you know people think we go to these
shows and it's just just fun and games
yeah you know but we're actually
grinding
and then you're doing translations and
you
man my hat is off to you and you deserve
scribe of the month definitely once
again all right so you can catch me on
twitter acting crazy
um i just went to my boy junior's house
so all right so a lot of people are
seeing uh pictures that are up
those are not my basement okay um my
basement
uh you probably saw a glimpse when i
came back from the hall that i got from
junior i went to junior now and i
cleaned out some of his statues
right so and i'm going back there to
clean out some more of his statues so
you know at four thousand a shot every
time i go see him so the next
three weeks i go back over there and get
four thousand dollars more more
statues oh thanks but uh
and then and then you saw me drop them
off at my house but i'm gonna give that
man all due respect uh uh for his statue
collecting he has
over five six hundred thousand dollars
worth of statues and he meticulously
places him in in his order and stuff and
he got more statues coming in so
one day we're gonna do a room tour with
him because i have a thing that i'm
working out
uh that i'm talking about with todd uh
from spec fiction so
if you guys uh do shop or purchase
statues please go to spec fishing and
check that out and mention my name
um you can catch me at kos as you know
uh
she-hulk be up this week uh we had a lot
of things that's going on
um much respect and i'm so happy that uh
uh miss cognito is uh doing
fantastic because it was hurting my
heart uh this week and it also hurt my
heart from my brother
so uh you know kos is going up i didn't
want to overload him or pd so i just you
know fell back
uh and i got a whole bunch of stuff
that's going to go up and darth castle x
this week uh fridays at uh
9 p.m we talk statues we talk
entertainment we talk comic books we we
talk at all you know we talk
these uh the comic cons and stuff like
that so uh come and give a listen come
check it out and see if you like it i'm
pretty sure that you would
oh oh and it's not um pg king
yeah yeah he loose you get loose
a long show i can't believe how much
time passed but how much fun yeah
it was good man i definitely needed this
it's been a rough rough week
and um just to see mama cognito turning
around and everyone said that love
much appreciated gaming and podcasting
is probably the most therapeutic thing
i could do during this period and it
truly helped me forget so salute to
y'all my brother's
addict king solved checking on me making
sure mentally i'm good
everybody in the team you know also
stepped up and took on more
responsibility whether it be iop or
lognet thank you and anybody who sent me
a dm
asking how i'm doing thank you as well
so much appreciate it and of course i
look to the guests manchester unto
jess corner for coming in and um
definitely giving us some great insight
information with being hands-on
with the acts i love windows central i
love what they're doing and it's really
cool to see that
and of course lords of gaming.net the
whole team you know i'm saying gene
absolute brother always a pleasure to
have you on the show always pleasure to
hit you hear your insight and i love the
fact that we have such a diverse
lineup of writers and everyone has their
own gaming perspective their own
favorites
and you know i just love that we putting
together something special that's
by the gamers right and that is just
cool to see so we always want to
celebrate that
and of course man you already know uh
the last word went up this week so if
you went to that destiny if you want to
get ready
many boxes had irl guardian on he is
amazing that man
is really a stunt man in films he's been
in
daredevil the netflix series amazing
spider-man he's been in many
top movies that you wouldn't even
realize uh doing the photo double for
your favorite stars
doing stuff the guy's amazing the
transformative destiny player
had a great time if you're into film and
film culture
and movies and martial arts check that
episode it's a fly episode
it's up on ironwood podcast right now
and yeah that's it man launching
gaming.netcognito on twitter and soft
and attic thank you for holding it down
with hosting and doing all that good
stuff while i get to guests and just
talk mess
the biggest thing i can say i enjoy
about this is i can control this stream
he can control the narrative
of course you have me lord lord
sovereign you can catch me on uh twitter
lordstop iop
um you know we know where i'm going now
right i'm going to learn you going over
don't worry go to work but um big shout
out to jess
um sean
you guys honestly listen we came i come
into the show today thinking we had no
guess that it was just going to be us
and that's that's fine
um but i think that's what's special
about our show like
all of a sudden we have three extra
people on the panel oh bro
shut up i forgot i don't even shot a
shark
capri like this guy's amazing like
please subscribe to him i'm sorry to
catch y'all i've completely you know
on my mind that i didn't shout him out
yeah he's a man he's such a positive
figure in the community if it wasn't for
nintendo guru i
kind of wouldn't have known about him so
salute the nintendo girl salute to a
separate go salute to mr bad bit because
i came across his content
truly amazing upbeat hilarious
mixes right in with our banter and also
one of
a fantastic content creator please
update me he's doing twitch
he one of my favorite canadians
salute brothers okay i got we got a lot
of canadians a lot larger
than that so i gotta yeah but
like i said like it's just one of those
things where you can have 10 people come
on to our podcast
and the energy and the love is going to
be the same like mm-hmm
and that's what i love about this so i'm
so glad that we
you know again we're on here almost
three and a half hours and nobody
you know bats and i so yeah we don't
know that it's three and a half hours
exactly
i'm back time let's go
for trusting me with the show um we'll
be back to normal next week
no we will not be back to normal because
we won't be back at 1 p.m
oh yeah it's not normal until
back to this crunch time i don't know i
beg to differ but you know
all right so with that said see you guys
next week
peace peace
hi this is lord sovereign from the iron
lord podcast
as you guys may recall a few months back
king david otw announced an amazing
giveaway for the xbox series x
while i'm proud to announce that the
iron lords podcast will once again be
giving away another console
at the end of this year and that console
will be a playstation
5. you heard correctly so
how do you get in on this amazing
giveaway let me explain
if you're already a member of the realm
you're good to go if you support us
either on patreon
or youtube you already have a ballot to
win this
amazing console and if you support us on
both platforms
you have two ballots to win this amazing
console as you also have two ballots to
win an xbox series x
so if you're not a member of the realm
what are you waiting for
head on over to patreon.com go to the
iron lords podcast patreon page
become a member of the realm to get your
chance to win a playstation 5.
you can also join us on youtube iron
lord podcast
become a member of the realm and you
will also have a ballot to win a
playstation 5 console
and if you want to support us on both
platforms you'll have
two ballots for each system to win
either a playstation 5 console or of
course as king david said
and xbox series x this is an amazing
opportunity
that the iron lords podcasts are so
happy to bring to our community because
you guys give so much back to us
so again if you're not a member of the
realm yet what are you waiting for go
out
join the realm on either patreon or
youtube
and until next time i'll see you at the
round table